Und ich bin ein ganz großer Mensch.
Ich bin ein ganz großer Mensch.
Ich bin gespannt, wie das funktioniert. Jetzt zur Maul und Clown solche Sendung 58. Chaosradio, schönen guten Abend. Der Esel nennt sich immer zuerst, ich heiß Holger, ich drücke die Knöpfe. Und mit mir im Studio ist Frank, hallo Frank.
Hi.
Hi, hallo Andreas.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Und noch ein Andreas.
Nein, ich heiße nicht Andreas. Ich heiße Andy, aber eigentlich bin ich...
Kann ich mal deinen Personalausweis...
Nee. Kannst du auch nicht, aber Andreas heiße ich nicht. Echt nicht? Stimmt. Also jedenfalls, siehst du, die Stätigen ist auch gleich...
Ja, 58, schönen guten Abend. Mach doch mal Musik. Also ich hab jetzt diesen Knopf gedrückt.
Ja, ich könnte, wenn du diesen Knopf da mal drückst, und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert, so, kaputt. Musst du nur noch machen, diese Mikrophone-Auswahl, dann ist besser Lala.
Schönen guten Abend, wir melden uns gleich wieder, weil dann ist besser Lala. Dir geht's nicht so gut, Andy, ne?
Nee, ich hatte irgendwie so leichte Erführungs-Anfall-Problematik. Bist du der Arisch ein bisschen abgefallen?
Ich dachte, du hättest Viren jetzt, oder was?
Ich hab Magengrippe.
Ah ja, super, kann ich da auch was von haben? Ich muss ja in die Woche noch arbeiten.
Ja, auch schon überlegen, ob ich potze, aber... Ich bin unschuldig.
Gehört das dazu?
Niemals, Andy.
Wer ist denn der Komponist? Können wir uns mit dem mal...
Ähm, guck mal, ob sich das...
War ich verzweifelt, hab ich mir Dope on Plastik gekauft, aber... Scheint kacke zu sein.
Wir üben noch. Das ist meiner.
Ich hab sonst auch noch schön Lala bei, weil sudanische Gesänge hat mir neulich jemand auf so einem Server angeboten. Muss ich mal richtig zuchtwerder auswählen. Also wir üben das jetzt gerade hier mal, liebe Hörfunkfreunde.
So, wollen wir noch mal gucken, ob das funktioniert. Ach so, was ist das jetzt?
Das ist immer noch diese Drohung auf Plastik.
Du hast das als CD, das kannst du mir auch geben, dann kann ich das mit professionellem Equipment...
Hab ich eigentlich auch am Start. Sehr komisch.
Kimjas, worüber wollen wir heute mal reden?
Gesetze und Geheimdienste und Abhörungen über den Fassungsschutz, aber nur ein bisschen.
Werden wir darüber reden, hört ihr zu Hause Musik?
Klar.
Aber ihr müsst uns heute anrufen, und zwar ganz viel.
Wir wollten eigentlich darüber reden, wie, wenn sich Technologie so entwickelt und gesellschaftlich immer wichtiger wird, wieder so die Gelüste der Industrie aufkommen, diese Technologie zu kontrollieren, um dann mehr Geld zu verdienen, oder wie die Staaten gerne so gewisse Modifikationen mit der Technik vornehmen möchten, um ihre Bilder besser zu kontrollieren.
Was ja letztlich doch, glaube ich, fast dasselbe ist, oder?
Also es gibt ja global agierende Unternehmen, denen sind nationale Regierungen zunehmend unwichtig. Und wenn du dir zum Beispiel diese Auseinandersetzung um den Namensraum des Internets anguckst, da spielen Regierungen ein bisschen auch eine Nebenrolle. Weil dadurch, dass es eben die Fluchtmöglichkeit gibt, dass man eben nicht in seinem Land die Domain registrieren muss, sondern das auch woanders kann und das dann genauso flutscht, ist der Spielraum von Regierungen da schon kleiner geworden.
Obwohl die US-Regierungen ja doch versucht massiv Einfluss zu nehmen, wie man so liest.
Das versucht sie nicht, sondern die US-Regierungen sitzen einfach am ganz großen Hebel. Das Ganze ist sozusagen so eine Art kontrollierter Feldversuch. So lassen wir die Küken mal spielen und tun so, als kann man nichts mehr machen. Aber natürlich haben die das in sich ausgedacht.
Die damals Woodstock, also da hat ja auch die CIA das LSD verkauft.
Aha.
Die Firmen haben gemerkt, dass kräftig Lobbyarbeit viel günstiger ist, als Produkte sicher zu machen. Das heißt, die verbieten jetzt einfach alles, was ihre Produkte auf einer Sicherheit gefährden könnte. Und brauchen sich ja nicht weiter darum zu kümmern, weil die stecken die Leute einfach in Knast und Zweifelsfall und müssen sich nicht darum kümmern, ihre Sicherheit zu machen.
Haben wir ein prominentes Beispiel?
Ja, wir haben ganz konkret jetzt die Richtlinie 398 L0084 des Europäischen Parlaments und des Rates der EU zum rechtlichen Schutz von Zugangskontrollierten Diensten und von Zugangskontrolldiensten. Und dieses schöne Dokument ist eigentlich gedacht, um Leute, die PayTV gucken, ohne bezahlt zu haben, zu bestrafen. Nachdem es aber ohnehin schon in der Bundesrepublik eine strafbare Handlung ist, unter anderem durch § 265 A StGB Leistungserschleichung, zielt dieses Dokument viel großflächiger auf widerrechtlichen Zugriff, wie sie es bezeichnen oder was es hier auch werden soll, ab. Im konkreten Fall das Umgehen von Zugangskontrollsystemen. Nun ist die Frage, was ist ein Zugangskontrollsystem? Was ist eine illegale Vorrichtung? Und da gibt es in diesem Dokument recht weit gefasste und, wie wir meinen, zu weit gefasste Formulierungen.
Und das ist das entscheidende vielleicht, um es notatisch etwas kürzer zu fassen, ist die Formulierung, dabei wurde unter anderem von den Unternehmen gefordert, bei bestehenden Tatbeständen im Strafrecht das digitale Element, hier ein Anführungszeichen, bei bestehenden Strafbeständen eindeutig und ausdrücklich zu berücksichtigen. In Klammern digitale Informationen als strafewertes Schutzgut. Das heißt, wenn du in Zukunft aus deinem Computer Informationen hast, mit denen man eine Leistungserstreichung begehen könnte, dann bist du bereits...
Nein, das zählt ja noch auf was anderes ab. Das heißt ja, dass ein digitaler Diebstahl höher bewertet werden soll als ein materieller Diebstahl. Das liest das Interpreter, ich daraus. Das ist halt beim Strafmaß besonders zu berücksichtigen. Das ist, dass die Daten digital sind. Das heißt also, du wirst wahrscheinlich für eine Napster-Freigabe, also wenn du was über Napster anbietest, wahrscheinlich stärker für bestraft, als wenn du zu Saturn gehst und dann eine CD klaust.
Ja klar.
Das ist jetzt so meine Kleinerinterpretation davon.
Würde ich aber auch plausibel finden. So wie es interpretiert wird, weil in dem Moment, wo du natürlich digital was klaust, ist es ja belebig reproduzierbar. Und in dem Moment, wo du materiell was klaust, ist das ja nicht unbedingt.
Die Frage ist ja, wie konsequent setzen wir das um? Werden Sie einfach alle Computer verbieten? Weil das sind ja potenziell Instrumente zur Beseitigung von Urheberrechtsschutzmechanismen und zur Dienstleistungserschleichung. Oder werden Sie nur die entsprechenden Programme? Jetzt schalte ich mal die Musik um. Ich sehe, das funktioniert nicht. Das ist ja toll.
Spiel doch mal die professionellen, hochwertigen CD-Player.
Ist doch alles prima. Dann spulen wir jetzt nochmal zurück, fangen die Sendung nochmal von vorne an und dann überlegen wir uns nochmal ganz kurz, worüber wir reden, okay?
Chaosradio 58, wir haben uns jetzt sortiert und gesammelt und uns entschlossen, nicht über das Thema der Sendung zu reden, sondern erstmal ein paar Neuigkeiten zu vermelden, oder?
Na ja, Neuigkeiten, wir wollten eigentlich ein, zwei Dinge erklären, die in den Medien vielleicht schon berichtet wurden, aber die dann oft missverstanden werden. Beispielsweise gab es da die Meldung der CIA, die ist jetzt von nahe auch schon zwei Wochen her, dass ein gewisser Laden offenbar das Internet dazu benutzt, um seine Kommunikationen im terroristischen Organisationssinn über Porno-Bilder zu betreiben. Das heißt, er wird sozusagen verdächtigt, im Internet Porno-Forum zu betreiben, wo entsprechende Bilder nackter Menschen dazu dienen, um darin eingeschmuggelte Informationen, also Steganographie sozusagen getarnt mit Bildern, zu transportieren.
Steganographie, für die, die es nicht wissen, ist also Daten in einem Bild verstecken und es damit verschlüsseln, also unsichtbar machen.
Das klingt allerdings auf der anderen Seite ein bisschen mehr so, als wollte die CIA reuchtfertigen, dass sie den ganzen Tag Pornos an Bildschirme gucken.
Wir empfangen hochgeheimne Nachrichten.
Wir sind den Tätern auf der Spur. Ja, in dem Zusammenhang wurde auch über PGP geredet mal wieder. Das heißt, es wurde mal wieder darüber geredet, wie bedroht die amerikanische Nation, dann sei, wenn sich Verschlussungsprogramme weltweit frei verbreiten würde. Da ist jetzt zwar noch keine konkrete Anfindung erfolgt, aber zumindest ist das möglicherweise schon ein Link mit dem Zhaunfall. Parallel hat Phil Zimmermann...
Sie diskutieren wahrscheinlich ums Geld, um den Etat, eine Debatte um den Etat.
Sie diskutieren gerade darum, die Beschränkungen für Kryptoexporte wieder aufleben zu lassen.
Genau, darum geht es.
Das hat aber doch schonmal nicht geklappt.
Diesmal ist die Situation allerdings andersrum. Phil Zimmermann, der Erfinder, muss man wohl sagen, geistige Vater von PGP, der das Produkt dann irgendwann an... Wie hieß dieses?
Network Associates.
Network Associates verkauft hat. So Weiterentwicklung hat jetzt das Unternehmen verlassen. Da gab es einige Stunden. Ihm gefielen wohl so Mauscheln, die Insider, da bestimmte Sachen eingebaut waren, wie beispielsweise dieses Additional Decryption Keys, das also mit der Argumentation, wenn kommerzieller Einsatz von Verschüßung erfolgen würde und dann ein Angestellter eines Unternehmens mal vom Bus überrollt wird, dann muss ja das Unternehmen noch Zugriffsmöglichkeiten auf diese verschützten Texte haben. Und solche und andere Sachen waren wohl der Hintergrund, dass Fülzmermann dann irgendwann gesagt hat, ihm gefällt der, land ich mir, er hat dann so eine Abschiedsmail geschrieben, jetzt vergangenen Montag, glaube ich, wo er dann natürlich mehrfach drauf besteht. Da wird er auch gut für bezahlt sein, dass PGP nach wie vor eines der sichersten Produkte überhaupt sei und seines Wissens nach keine Hintertürchen enthalten und so weiter und so fort. Also es bleibt abzuwarten, was jetzt passiert. PGP möchte offenbar zukünftige Versionen von, also Network-assiziert von PGP, nicht mehr im Source Code, das heißt nicht mehr mit dem Quellcode verbreiten, sondern wegen dem Schutz ihres geistigen Eigentüms und den üblichen Begründigungsfloskeln diesen zurückhalten.
Gut, das heißt, ich benutze demnächst PGP nicht mehr, um meine E-Mails zu verschließen, was benutze ich denn dann?
GPG Privacy Guard benutze, www.gnu.pg.org. Das ist zwar noch nicht für alle Plattformen verfügbar.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, jetzt kriege ich wieder Dresche, wenn ich frage, ob das auch für was anderes als Unix...
Ja, es ist schon für Windhof, ist es glaube ich, schon zu haben. Aber mit der Mac-Version lassen die Jungs noch, also Mac OS X klar, aber das ist ja eigentlich kein Mac OS X.
Das ist das Projekt, was von der Bundesregierung...
Da hat das Wirtschaftsministerium in der Tat auch einen Markt dazugegeben. Aber die, ich glaube, GNU-PG sind jetzt schon bei der 1.0.
Die sind bei 1.04.
1.04, ja gut. Das heißt, sie haben schon irgendwie einen offiziellen Release, aber noch nicht für alle Plattformen und auch noch nicht für alle Mailer, also so ganz clicky-bunty.
Ich meine, Linux gibt es, Windows gibt es, aber dann haben wir doch glaube ich erst mal 90% abgedeckt der Bevölkerung, oder? Keine Ahnung.
Problem sind noch die bestehenden Schlüssel. Also GNU-PG ist eine Implementation des OpenPGP-Standards, um den sich auch Phil Zimmermann in Zukunft kümmern möchte, zusammen mit einer amerikanischen Firma, die eine OpenPGP-Implementation für kommerzielle Nutzer anbieten möchten. Und GPG kann offiziell noch keine RSA-Schlüssel, also bestehende Schlüssel auf dem RSA-Verfahren. Es gibt allerdings einen noch nicht als offiziell deklarierten Patch dafür, damit er das kann. Da gibt es aber wiederum Interoperabilitätsprobleme mit Windows-Versionen größer 658, also den neuesten Versionen von PGP, die am Markt sind. Die können mit GNU-PG nicht kommunizieren.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt noch mit PGP Schlüssel generiere, dann mit einer möglichst alten Version, damit GNU-PG das auch kann?
Mit einer möglichst neuen. Die neuen Schlüssel, die VCR-Heading-Schlüssel, sind schon in GNU-PG. Die RSA-Schlüssel kann GNU-PG schon, aber GNU-PG kann dann nur mit alten PGP-Versionen kommunizieren, nicht mit neuen.
Wie war die Adresse www.gnu.pg.org?
Genau.
Was aber vielleicht noch interessant ist dabei, das Problem ist also nicht nur, dass es sowas für Windows gibt, sondern du willst auch als Plugins deine Mails haben, also sprich für Outlook, Pandora und so.
Karte Paste kann dich ja mal machen, oder?
Na ja, das macht schon wesentlich einfacher. Und je einfacher sowas ist, desto mehr Leute benutzen es auch. Und nur wenn sie 99% benutzen, dann fällt der einzelne nicht mehr auf die einzelnen Mails, die dann verschlüsselt werden. Das ist ja gerade das Problem, und das wird wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen Thema der Sendung sein. Das heißt, im Moment ist es so, dass ich irgendwie noch auffalle, wenn ich sicher kommuniziere. Das ist allerdings richtig.
Richtig, ja. Ich bin gespannt, ihr da mit zu sehen Ich bin gespannt, was ihr da mit uns zu sehen habt Ich gespannt ihr da mit sehen. 22.31. Das Wetter erst mal nachts, kaum noch Schnee, minus fünf bis minus zehn Grad morgen, anfangs dann trübe Späteraufheiterungen bei minus einem bis plus zwei Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Jörg Popendieck.
Die israelische Arbeitspartei hat sich im Abend für eine Koalition mit dem rechtsgerichteten Likud-Block des künftigen Ministerpräsidenten Sharon ausgesprochen. Für eine Regierungsbeteiligung hatten vor allem Friedensnobelpreisträger Shimon Peres geworden. Sharon hatte am 6. Februar die Ministerpräsidentenwahl für sich entschieden und löst Amtsinhaber Barack von der Arbeitspartei ab. In Bonn hat sich der zentrale Krisenstab des Bundesverbraucherministeriums auf ein Sechs-Punkte-Programm gegen die Maul- und Clown-Seuche verständigt. In Großbritannien wurden unterdessen weitere Fälle der Seuche bekannt. Die Europäische Union öffnet ihre Märkte für Produkte aus der Dritten Welt. Die EU-Außenminister billigten in Brüssel gegen den Willen, Frankreich sei eine entsprechende Vorlage der EU-Kommission. Die Zollbeschränkungen sollen langsam liberalisiert und bis zum Jahr 2009 völlig abgeschafft werden. Im Fall der verschwundenen Ulrike aus Eberswalde ist der Fahrer eines weißen Pkw tatverdächtig. Nach dem etwa 20 bis 30 Jahre alten 1, 75 m großen Mann werde bundesweit gefahren, sagt er heute einen Polizeisprecher ab. Der Verkehr A13 drehst schöne Felder Kreuz zwischen Kipplitz und Spreewald, behindert ein defektes Fahrzeug, den Verkehrskamms im Stau kommen. Und in Berlin und Brandenburg ist es glatt und neblig, also Fuß vom Gas.
Also Fuß vom Gas. Vielen Dank, Herr Koppendieck, 22.30.
Okay, ihr seid halt nicht ganz allein mit ihr. Nicht? Naja, es könnte sein, dass am 25. März, ein Sonntag übrigens, und auch noch der, an dem die Sommerzeit beginnt, also es könnte sein, dass an diesem Tag noch ein paar andere Leute in der Columbia-Halle sind.
Aber?
Immerhin. Also, Kylie Minogue kommt für eine Nacht nach Berlin.
Solta, 25. März, 20 Uhr, Columbia Halle.
Licht ausgemacht, von Fritz.
Schönen guten Abend. Wir sind gerade immer noch dabei, wissenswertes zu vermelden und zu berichten, bevor wir mit dem eigentlichen Thema anfangen. Was wolltest du?
Wissenswertes nach zwei Geschichten noch eine Nachreichend für diejenigen, die das nicht mitgeschnappen bin. Laden ist der junge Mann, der verdächtig wird, unter anderem mit einigen freiwilligen Helfern dann so dicke Löcher in amerikanische Flugzeugträger gesprengt zu haben, wo dann mehrere Elefanten durch die Wand im Seifelsfall hindurch passen.
Und welche Elefanten tragen jetzt die Erde?
Na, das ist eine andere Frage, weil das sind ja nicht Elefanten, das sind ja Monster, aber zu den Monstern später mehr zu bin Laden nicht mehr. Was noch erwähnt wird, es gab einen interessanten Hack beim World Economic Forum in Davos, das ist irgendwo in der Schweiz, wo ein paar Jungs eigentlich ganz harmlos was gemacht haben. Die sind nämlich nur durch die Teilnehmerliste mal so ein bisschen durchgebraust und haben sich deren persönliche Daten und Kreditkartennummern und ähnliches heruntergeladen. Also darunter halt so bei Clinton und Arafat und sonst wie. Alles wie gesagt mit Kreditkartennummern und so fort. Eigentlich haben die echt nichts Böses gemacht.
Das internationale Wirtschaftsforum ist nicht in der Lage, Teilnehmerdaten zu sichern und schreibt gleichzeitig noch Sicherheit.
Nein, Computer Sicherheit gibt es ja nicht. Das war so ein Thema auf der Konferenz, aber ne, ne, das gibt es tatsächlich nicht. Und was die eigentlich gemacht haben, war was Heldenhaftes. Die haben also zur Förderung des öffentlichen Bewusstseins alles was sie darunter gesaugt haben auf eine CD-Rom gebrannt und die der Schweizer Sonntagszeitung oder so geschickt, die das dann genüsslich daraus zitiert hat und ähnliches. Jetzt sind die Schweizer Behörden allerdings ein bisschen halbentspannt und haben jetzt also Strafanzeigen und masslich alles gestellt. Ja, eigentlich kann man denen nichts vorwerfen, weil die haben mit den Daten ja nichts gemacht. Sie hatten ja auch Clinton noch den einen oder anderen Besuch in interessanten Etablissements auf seine Kreditkarte anhängen können oder so.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich finde es eigentlich total schick, wenn Schröder mir die CDs bei Amazon bezahlen würde.
Und sie haben noch nicht mal wirklich was Böses gemacht, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe. Das lag wohl irgendwie offen. Sie haben nicht mal das Schloss, sondern sie haben einfach nur die Tür an der Klinke aufgemacht.
Das heißt, das hätte sogar ich geschafft, ja?
Na ja.
Okay.
Aber ja, da reden wir nochmal drüber. Ja, machen wir dann jetzt, ja?
Die Firma Network Solutions, NSI, vielen bekannt früher als Monopolist für die Domain-Registrierung, hat beschlossen, sie vermarkten jetzt die Daten, die ihnen zwangsweise für die Registrierung übermittelt wurden und verkaufen die.
Ja, und zwar gleich sortiert nach sogenannten E-Commerce-Betreibern. Da wird dann mit automatischen Suchmaschinen danach gesucht, ob sowas wie Shop hier oder Credit Card, Lambda, Plug-in, Blabel da draufsteht. Ja, das Interessante daran ist, dass diese ganze Handhabung der Domain-Namen bei Network Solutions nach amerikanischem Recht stattfindet. Da gibt es halt sowas wie Datenschutz im Wesentlichen mal gar nicht. Und Network Solutions selbst hat relativ verschlungene Bedingungen, wo sie so gesagt haben, naja, die Daten, die wir da haben, die haben wir halt. Und also haben sich keine Generalklauseln gegeben. Und das ist natürlich so ein bisschen blöd, weil der Laden lange Zeit monopolistisch quasi als Registrie, das heißt als die Datenbank, in der die Com Org-Netz und anregionärische Troppler-Volumens gespeichert sind, agiert. Das ist also total nicht sehr lustig und nicht mal umgehbar. Dann haben wir noch was Neues vom Flohmarkt. Andreas hat da eine Meldung im Netz gefunden, die wir euch nicht vorenthalten möchten.
Die deutsche Presseagentur hat vermeldet, dass die Bundeswehr den Standort Bad Eibling schließen wird, der die Überwachungsanlage der NSL bewacht.
Also um das nochmal kurz zu erklären und zu sagen, warum das wirklich ein Schnäppchen ist. Die National Security Agency hat in Bad Eibling, das ist so 60, 70 Kilometer vor München in Richtung Österreich, einen Standort, wo jede Telekommunikation der Bundesrepublik Deutschland mit dem Ausland einmal durch Lauf wirbt, durch die Anderen und nach Stichworten durchsucht wird. Pullach ist der Nachbarort, wo der Bundesnachrichtendienst sitzt, der...
Das ist dieser super geheime Geheimdienst, von dem man nie mitkriegt, was er macht.
mit der Lufthansa schmuggelt und lauter tolle Sachen macht. Und der darf eben laut Gesetz diese Telekommunikation überwachen. Allerdings haben sie aus praktischen Erwägungen die NSA als Outsourcing-Dienstleister in die Pflicht genommen. Das heißt, weil der BND die technische Kompetenz nicht hat, machen das die Amerikaner, die Deutschen, liefern also ihre Telekommunikation und die Stichworte auf aus, sozusagen Amerikaner und Amerikaner filtern dann und entscheiden dann, was sie meinen, den Deutschen geben zu müssen. Jetzt ist dieser Standort der Bundeswehr, der direkt vor Bad Alpling ist, also der vor der amerikanischen Militärinstallation ist, der wird jetzt geschlossen und wäre dann günstig zu haben. Der CCC bewirbt sich natürlich um dieses Grundstück. Allerdings geht das nur, wenn wir eure Spenden haben. Bitte auf Konto 8555 100 bei der Postbank Berlin. Bankerzahl 100 110.
Wenn ihr noch was übrig habt, könnt ihr auch noch diese weißen Kugeln auf dem Teufelsberg?
Der Teufelsberg ist ebenfalls, ja, also das ist auch interessant, die werden ja in Schuss gehalten.
Da wird jetzt ein Hotel gebaut. Es war gerade im Januar oder so was kam das irgendwie in der Zeitung, dass es gekauft wurde und dass da jetzt ein hochsichtiges Hotel mit Whirlpools und so.
Ja, Andreas, du hast noch was?
Ja, die Firma Google Incorporated, ein Betreiber einer populären Suchmaschine, hat die Firma Deja Incorporated gekauft, die ein Archiv des Usenets über die letzten fünf Jahre hinweg besitzen.
Also Datensammlung als Kulturgut.
Und ja, hier stellt sich die Frage nachdem, also diese Firma besitzt ein vollständiges Archiv des Usenets. Das ist eine elektronische Diskussion vor allem im Internet und dieses Archiv wurde bisher zur Einsicht bereitgestellt, dann konnte sich diese Firma nicht mehr finanzieren, hat begonnen, aufgrund der Postings in diese Newsgruppen zielgruppenspezifisches Marketing zu machen und Produkte zu bewerben.
Deja come before you buy.
Und es ging aber leider schief, ist nicht aufgegangen mit der Finanzierung und die Firma Google hat nun Deja aufgekauft, hat die Schnittstelle und den Zugang zu diesen Daten geändert und bietet die jetzt als Teil ihrer Suchtdienstleistungen an und die Frage stellt sich aber, was wird mit diesen Daten passieren? Die befinden sich in der privaten Hand eines US-Unternehmens und Na ja, die sind ja sowieso für jeden eigentlich zugänglich oder nicht?
Gewesen.
Gewesen. Das hat sich gerade geändert. Sie bieten jetzt nur noch Zugriff auf das letzte halbe Jahr.
Halbe Jahr nur?
Halbe Jahr.
Ich meine bis 95.
Sie haben die Daten bis 95. Sie bieten aber nur noch den Zugang über das letzte halbe Jahr mit dem Argument, sie müssten jetzt ihr Interface dazustricken und das umbasteln. Die Frage ist, ob das eine vorläufige Entscheidung ist, um die Community zu beruhigen oder eine endgültige Entscheidung. Die Frage ist auch, wer hat das Copyright an diesen Daten? Haben das die Leute, die posten? Hat das diese Firma?
Ich meine, wer die Daten hat, der kann sie ja benutzen an sich oder kann sie ja weiter speichern. Das ist ja kein Problem.
Das ist eine rechtliche Frage. Die Erwägungen in den USA gehen dahin, dass Menschen fordern, dass beispielsweise die Library of Congress eben dieses digitale Stück Kultur gut sichern sollte und nicht ein privatwirtschaftlich betriebenes Unternehmen.
Das können wir ja mal versuchen, der Bundesregierung zu erklären. Welcher?
Unsere oder der?
Haben wir da nicht so eine komische…
Ach so, unsere Bundesregierung.
Ich dachte du meinst die US.
Wir hören es wahrscheinlich zu der Fraktion, die auch schon meint, wir müssten eigentlich hier mit den Amerikanern wählen, wobei, Unikation-Wahlverfahren haben sie ja nicht bewehrt. Aber gut.
Wieso? Jetzt haben die einen Präsidenten, über den wir uns köstlich amüsieren können.
Na ja, also ich will ja zufrieden auf Erden, eine gute Gesinnung für jedermann und Frau. Also jetzt gerade eine Packung Salzstangen. Ja, perfekt.
Und Bush ist übrigens ganz stark gegen Labster, hat er heute wohl gesagt.
Ja Bush, hat ja auch Probleme. Was hat er gesagt? Am Freitag war das glaube ich, ist er auf die Kokainernte in Kolumbien angesprochen worden, hat Kakao verstanden und hat gesagt, es sei unglaublich besorgt.
Es sei unglaublich besorgt über die Kakaoplantagen.
Interessant. Wobei Kolumbien ja das einzige Land der Welt ist, die Kokain in ihrem Bruttosozialprodukt ausweisen.
Nein.
Doch.
Kann man das da auf Rechnung kaufen, oder wie?
Nein, das nicht, aber da es ein nennenswerter Anteil der Agrarwirtschaft des Landes ist, fühlen die das einfach mit auf?
Das ist wohl in Laos auch so. Also anders kann die da nicht irgendwie in die Erfnung, welche Zahlen kommen.
Da bist du wohl in diesem Bereich besser informiert als ich.
Gibt es eigentlich in Laos Computer? Ist egal.
Nein, gibt es nicht.
Aber Moment, dann kommt jetzt noch Fidel Castro. Fidel Castro wird von den USA verdächtigt, der weltgrößte Hacker zu sein. Das kam jetzt gerade vor wenigen Tagen in Zusammenhang mit dieser Binladin Nummer, ihr wisst schon, das mit dem Flugzeugträger und den Elefanten. Raussuch Fidel der Hacker. Da wird also behauptet, dass Fidel Castro jetzt die neue Bedrohung für die amerikanische Informationsinfrastruktur sei.
Da ist wieder sein Name Binladin.
Ja, da ist auch wieder der Binladin erwähnt. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob Fidel Castro viel mit Binladin zu tun hat. Ich finde Fidel Castro macht immer so einen friedlichen Eindruck.
Ja, bis auf die Uniform macht er einen sehr friedlichen Eindruck.
Ja gut, man redet dann mal ein bisschen über das Ergebnis der Zuckerrohrernte oder so, aber das sind ja verzeihliche menschliche Schwächen, oder?
Ein bisschen Werbung habe ich noch. Echt? Und zwar, Holger hat mir nicht erzählt, dass hier immer ganz viele Anfragen kommen. Wir wissen, dass dann mit Internet, den Literaturen alle Flatrate haben und bei der Telekom dauert es so lange.
DSL-Fatrate.
Genau, und jetzt gibt es irgendwie was Schickes von einem Mitbewerber von der Telekom, nämlich Akur Mannesmann, die irgendwie auch für 110 Mark DSL-Flatrate bieten, was ja eigentlich erstmal nicht so was Besonderes ist. Aber sie haben die Chance, das tatsächlich auch zu machen, weil sie benutzen nämlich Alcatel-Technologie für DSL, und das heißt, dass sie damit auch in Opal-Gebieten ankommen. Opal heißt optische Anschlussleitung, das ist eine Technologie, die die Telekom vor gut zehn Jahren in den neuen Bundesländern und vielen Teilen von Ostberlin in die Erde geworfen hat. Nur hat dann irgendwie, Alcatel hat es mal ein bisschen verkackt mit der Vertragserfüllung, und da hat dann die Telekom-Vorstand beschlossen, so nö, von denen kaufen wir jetzt nichts mehr. Und es ist irgendwie der Stand seit ein paar Jahren. Und wer zum Beispiel in Friedrichshain wohnt, braucht sich irgendwie keine Hoffnung machen, dass er irgendwann in den nächsten Jahren nochmal DSL von der Telekom kriegen wird.
Von Arcor aber wahrscheinlich dann doch, weil...
Ja, die Chancen stehen gut, weil die verwenden nämlich zufälligerweise nur Alcatel-Technologie und da biete sich das an, das so direkt einzubauen. Das würde noch auf Platzamt zutreffen.
Aber dieser Anteil war abgeschickt und wir schauen mal.
Das ist Panic-Gear, weil noch nicht erprobt.
Genau, ist noch nicht erprobt, aber zuversichtlich.
Genau, außerdem gibt es ja dann auch noch eine normale Flatrate von Arcor jetzt, also eine analoge ISDN für 70 Mark als Konkurrenz zur Telekom, die es ja eh bald nicht mehr gibt.
Genau, dann haben wir noch irgendwie was Neues aus der Abteilung mittelschlechte Nachrichten. Und zwar wird es mal wieder eine Volkszählung geben, mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit. Aber das Schöne ist, ihr merkt davon gar nichts.
Voll kratzerheit.
Das heißt jetzt Registerabgleich, wahrscheinlich nach dem Bundesmodell. Und daraus wird dann aus verschiedenen Registern, was wir uns bisher verboten ist, die zusammenzuführen, wird dann ein sogenannter kombinierter Datensatz oder sowas erstellt. Und naja, da werden wir mal schauen, wie das weitergeht. Da ist jetzt wohl ein bisschen was passiert, aber nichts genaues weiß man nicht. Und wir lassen uns überraschen, dass irgendwie nicht die Sommerpause oder die letzte Sitzung vor der Sommerpause dazu genutzt wird, das noch irgendwie nebenbei noch so durchzumogeln. Und plötzlich steht dann wieder Anfang nächsten Jahres so ein Herr vor der Tür mit so einem Bogen. Guten Tag, wie viele Kinder haben Sie, was verdienen Sie, was essen Sie zum Mittag? Und Ihre Telefonnummer hätten wir auch noch gern für Rückfragen.
Ich glaub, dieses dämliche Piep kommt doch von deinem Computer, Anni, ne?
Ja, sind bisschen.
Max, mach nochmal so komische Geräusche.
Weil ihr hier keinen DHCP habt, sondern irgendwelche kryptischen IP-Nummern.
Nein, nein, nein.
DHCP haben wir nicht, aber Anrufe haben wir. Hallo Pascal. Was, was wolltest du zu Ako sagen?
Ja genau, mit denen hab ich nämlich ganz miese Erfahrungen gemacht. Bei denen wollte ich so vor anderthalb Jahren oder so einen ISDN-Anschluss beantragen. Hab bei so einem netten Vertreter auf der Straße so einen Antrag ausgefüllt. Und hab dann auch gleich irgendwelche weiteren Formulare zugeschickt bekommen, die ich dann ausgefüllt habe. Und ja, dann gab es erstmal, hab ich irgendwie einen vier Monat oder so überhaupt nichts von denen gehört. Nachdem ich dann ein paar Mal da angerufen hatte, und da musste ich ewig an irgendeiner Hotline warten, die nicht kostenlos war. Weil die kostenlos irgendwie nicht für Kunden zuständig war oder so. Ja, nach ein paar Monaten habe ich dann irgendwie ein paar Briefe bekommen, dass die halt mit der Telekom da nicht zurechtkommen, irgendwie meinen vorherigen analogen Anschluss abzumelden. Das fand ich ja noch okay. Und dann habe ich weiterhin drei Monate gewartet, also nachdem ich da irgendwie weiterhin irgendwelche Formulare ausgefüllt hatte. So genau weiß ich das alles nicht mehr.
Wann war das?
Das war, also vor anderthalb Jahren hat das angefangen ungefähr. Und dann habe ich drei Monate gewartet, bis ich da Informationen gekriegt habe, dass sie da mit der Anmeldung bei der Telekom, oder mit der Abmeldung bei der Telekom nicht zurechtkommen. Und danach habe ich dann noch mal drei Monate gewartet, bis ich irgendwie eine Nachricht bekommen habe, so dass jetzt mein Antrag irgendwie aufgenommen wurde und die Bearbeitung so weiterläuft, dass ich bald möglichst meinen ISDN-Anschluss bei denen bekomme.
Das war aber so ein Stand auf der Straße? Also ich meine, so eine komische Bude, wie so eine Losbude, oder was war das?
Das sind dann noch mal Zwischenhändler, ne?
Ja, okay, aber das war ja dann nach den sechs Monaten müsste das ja dann wenigstens abgebildet werden. Jedenfalls habe ich dann nach diesen sechs Monaten wieder ein paar Monate gewartet, zwei oder so. Hab dann mich mehrere Male zwischendurch gemeldet, hab nachgefragt, was da los ist. Irgendwann konnten sie mir dann Auskunft geben und haben gesagt, ja, mein Antrag wurde eingestellt, weil sie von mir irgendeine Unterschrift vermissen, dass sie meinen Telekom Anschluss abmelden können. Die hatte ich ihnen aber schon drei Monate vorher zugeschickt, anstatt mich mal darüber zu informieren, dass sie die nicht erhalten haben oder so. Dann dachte ich mir, habe ich irgendwie bessere Angebote gesehen.
Um das an dieser Stelle mal abzukürzen, du telefonierst gerade nicht über Arco, oder?
Nee, jetzt telefoniere ich über die Berlikons.
Die sind ja auch nicht besser. Morgen sind wir uns der letzte Zeitpunkt zum Kündigen, um euer Sonderkündigungsrecht wahrzunehmen. Morgen? Ja, übermorgen. Also morgen müssen wir die abschicken wegen Poststempel und so, weil die ja von Flatrate jetzt umgestiegen sind auf Minute-Tarife, was die Internet einwahl. Und das ist eigentlich eine ganz, ganz böde Sache. Und dafür bekommen sie irgendwie ordentlich auf den Popo und hoffentlich schicken morgen noch ganz, ganz viele Leute ihre Berlikon-Kündigung ab. Weil es war nämlich wirklich nicht nett, was sie da gemacht haben.
Ja, ich dachte, da hätte ich noch länger Zeit.
Pascal, wir danken für deinen Anruf.
Ja, ich wollte noch sagen, dass ich denn von AQOR irgendwann angefangen habe, Rechnungen zu bekommen für die Monatsgrundgebühr.
Von mir sehen die keinen Fähnchen, bevor ich nicht mein erstes Bitt durch die Leitung gekriegt habe.
Ja, genau. Zum Glück hatte ich vorher mein Konto geändert, sodass die mit ihren Abbruchungen irgendwie ins Leere gelaufen sind.
Gut, vielen Dank für die AQOR-Warnung, Pascal. Idealerweise hast du ja eben gesagt, Frank, machen wir es so, wir behalten einen analogen Anschluss bei der Telekom, einfach so zum Telefonieren.
Genau, weil Voice ist nämlich bei AQOR richtig teuer. Die wollen irgendwie so einen Minutentaktabrechnung nur und 24 fände ich nach Nordamerika. Das ist alles nicht so prall. Also einfach noch einen Analoganschluss dazu oder irgendwie sowieso nur Handy. Braucht man zu Hause Festnetz-Telefon eigentlich nicht?
Na ja, das ist schon ganz schön. Ich neige dazu abends dann auch schon mal stundenlang mit fremden Menschen, also nee, mit mir bekannten Menschen, zu telefonieren, die aber nicht direkt nebenan wohnen oder so. Dafür wär's ganz gut. Und dann einen Zweitanschluss von AQOR und darüber DSL machen. Du wirst sagen, das funktioniert, oder? Sie ist kurz vor elf, also quasi elf und darum haben wir hier hüpfelstimmel. Und zwar das Chaosradio 58 hier auf Fritz. Wir hatten, was hatten wir, also eben eine Arcoerwarnung, Berlikon Sonderkündigungsrecht bis spätestens morgen wahrnehmen.
Ja und ich hab da gleich noch einen Übergang zum Thema, damit wir mal auf einem allgemeinen Geplauderefleck auf unser konkretes Thema Überwachung und Gesetzgebung kommen. In dem Fall aber noch Überwachung durch technische Betreiber. Die Berlikon hat uns gegenüber eine nicht zitierfähige Aussage gemacht, dass Datenverbindungen nicht in ihrem Interesse seien und sie stichpunktartig Verbindungen kontrollieren würden, bei etwa insgesamt 15.000 Anschlüssen und das Telefonieverhalten auswerten würden. Da stellt sich mir doch die Frage, inwieweit das a, juristisch haltbar ist und b, ein korrektes Verfahren, was ich von meinem Netzbetreiber sehen möchte, das eher stichpunktartig meine Verbindungen kontrolliert.
Das kleineste aus der Zeitung hab ich noch, nämlich der Berliner Verfassungsschutz, ist ja neu strukturiert worden und da gibt es auch eine neue Leiterin, nämlich die Claudia Schmidt, und die wurde irgendwie von der City interviewt und der hat sie dann sowas Schönes gesagt, wie, naja, sinngemäß, wenn die halt extremistische Gruppen für nicht ganz so gefährlich halten, dann muss man sich mit dem Einsatz Nachrichtendienstlicher mit eher zurückhalten, das heißt, die werden schon abhören, also Nachrichtendienstliche Mittel heißt es im Wesentlichen abhören und sowas, aber sie werden, naja, halt nicht ganz so doll, aber schon irgendwie und darauf verzichten kann man ja nicht, also das ist irgendwie schon ganz klar, wie sie da weiterarbeiten werden. Und was Schönes hat sie auch noch gesagt, wir werden unsere Erkenntnisse und Ideen an Schulen vermitteln. So, jetzt geht der Verfassungsschutz in die Schulen und dann werden wir... Ah, hallo!
Euer Lehrer hat gestern...
Wollt ihr nicht?
Das gab es in der DDR gestimmt, oder?
Ja, das mit dem Lernen aus der Geschichte haben wir in Deutschland nie so.
Welche Geschichte?
Und das Schöne ist, dass wir auch bei dieser ganzen Napster-Diskussion aus der Sicht geraten, dass nämlich irgendwie das zu 90-95% verbreitete Betriebssystem Windows bietet ja eine ganz wunderbare File-Sharing Option, nämlich einfach Windows-Freigaben einfach aufzumachen. Das ist irgendwie simpel, die sind teilweise sogar default-offen, das heißt ich brauche mich gar nicht darum kümmern, keine böde Software nirgendswo registrieren, ich mach einfach irgendwie diesen Ordner freigeben und das ist dann sogar noch fast default-offen.
Also Moment, ich installiere mein Windows, klicke aus, da sind den falschen Knopf und dann lädst du dir Dateien bei mir runter, das heißt auch Windows macht genau dasselbe wie Napster.
Angeschaltet beim installieren. Ja, das ist so.
Man muss halt noch die Rechner finden, aber das ist ja kein Problem.
Es gibt keine zentrale Suchfunktion wie bei Napster, aber ich glaube, das ist vorhanden.
Ja gut, aber trotzdem leistet Windows doch dann Verletzungen des Urheberrechts vor.
Wir warten ja noch auf die erwähnte Richtlinie der Europäischen Union 98-84-EG, wo dann möglicherweise Windows in der Tat als Werkzeug zur Verbreitung und so weiter und so fort verboten wird.
Vielleicht mal ein bisschen was zum Thema heute.
Ja, das wär jetzt auch mal ein Vorschlag gewesen. Willst du vielleicht nochmal sagen, was das Thema genau ist so?
Also der Titel war so ungefähr...
Reale Gesetze gegen... oder und virtuelle Straftaten. Reale Gesetze gegen virtuelle Straftaten. Der Titel ist mit Absicht ein bisschen mystisch gewählt und irgendwie interpretationsfähig. Und wir wollen uns eigentlich mal darüber unterhalten, was vor allem verhältnismäßig ist und was angemessen ist an Einschränkungen an Grundrechten, um jetzt diese digitalen Rechte, wie zum Beispiel das Urheberrecht oder Leistungserschleichung von Fernsehprogrammen wie auch immer, irgendwie sowas durchzusetzen. Selbstlich durchzusetzen und dann auch sowas wie Telefonabhörmaßnahmen, E-Mail, Filtern, abhören, wie sowas dann durchgesetzt wird. Wie ist das überhaupt angemessen oder werden wir dazu sehr beschränkt? Was hat die Regierung, was haben die Regierung vor? Was wird da der nächste Zeit auf uns zukommen? Das ist so das Thema.
So, Chaosradio 58, jetzt reden wir wirklich mal über reale Gesetze gegen virtuelle Straftaten, würde ich vorschlagen, oder?
Naja, ich meine wir haben ja gerade den Hörer an einen großen Dienst erwiesen.
Natürlich.
Wir haben eine Sache nicht auf dem Sender diskutiert, wenn der Hörer an uns herantut, nämlich wie das bei der AOL-Konfiguration ist. Und deswegen dachte ich, machen wir jetzt erstmal die AOL-Gedenkminute.
Genau.
Ok, ja das eigentliche Thema der Sendung, da sollte es ja zum Beispiel anlässlich der jüngst vorgestellten Telekommunikationsüberwachung im zweiten Entwurf darum gehen, was die sogenannte Telekommunikations-Beregulierung zum Beispiel in Deutschland uns gebracht hat. Weil was sie uns nicht gebracht hat, das in der ersten Stunde diskutiert, ist nämlich eine sinnvolle Flatrate mit statischen IP-Adressen zum tollen Preis. Das haben wir alle nicht, aber was wir haben, ist im Telekommunikationsgesetz den sogenannten elften Teil, wo die Befugnisse des Staates geregelt sind, beispielsweise Telekommunikation oder die sogenannten Begleitumstände der Telekommunikation, wozu zum Beispiel gehört werden, ein Mobiltelefon telefoniert nicht nur mit wer, mit wem telefoniert und was sie sprechen, sondern auch wo sich dieses Telefon befinden. So, und dieses Telekommunikationsgesetz hat halt einen Haufen Gesetze, wo man eigentlich sagen kann, das ist keine Deregulierung, sondern genau das Gegenteil. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt mehr Gesetze, die staatliche Befugnisregelung bislang fehlt, ist allerdings an der Verordnung. Das heißt, der sogenannte Rechtsstaat funktioniert im Wesentlichen darauf, dass es Gesetze gibt, die dann wiederum in Verordnungen sozusagen umgesetzt werden. Und am Ende der Kette steht dann die technische Richtlinie, wo dann tatsächlich bis aufs Bild genau festgehalten ist, wo jetzt welchem Bundesnachrichtendienst oder welchem Amt für Verfassungsschutz welche Daten in welcher Reihenfolge zuzusenden sind, an welche IP-Nummer und so weiter zu fahren. Es gab zwar schon mal den Versuch, so der Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung, den Providern, also denjenigen, die Telekommunikationsdienstleistungen für andere geschäftsmäßig erbringen, aufzudrücken. Der Versuch wurde aber vor anderthalb Jahren, wenn ich mich recht kenne, vor zwei Jahren von der Industrie sozusagen unter lauter Empörung zurückgewiesen, weil das sei alles viel zu teuer. Da war nicht nur geregelt, dass es so automatische Schnittstellen geben sollte, wo die sogenannten Bedarfsträger dann ihre Datengelüste befriedigen können, sondern auch noch, dass diese Schnittstellen eben von den Providern finanziert werden sollten.
Wobei das jetzt immer noch so ist.
Ja, das ist jetzt komischerweise noch genauso. Sie haben das Papier überarbeitet und haben es geschafft, ein noch unbrüchschaubares Werk zu schaffen. Die erste Telekommunikationsverwaltungsverordnung hat wenigstens relativ klar und direkt gesagt, wir Staat, du Bürger, wir wollen alles. Jetzt sahen sie Ja und siehe Paragraphs So und So und wie sich ausgibt. Kannst du das mal zusammenfassen, Andreas, durch diesen Gesetzeswusst schon gelesen?
Was es für euch zumindest bedeutet, heißt, ihr seid am Internetzugang bei einem Provider und dieser Provider muss für relativ viel Geld, also das ist im deutlichen Millionenbereich, muss er da Technik hinstellen, damit die Bedarfsträger, also die Nachrichtendienste, die Polizei da abhören kann. Die machen das ja auch nicht, weil sie gerade zu viel Geld haben, die Provider, sondern die müssen das irgendwie umlegen auf die Kosten. Das heißt, ihr zahlt dann mit jeder Minute Internet dafür, dass ihr da drüber auch abgehört werdet.
Richtig, weil der Staat nämlich die Telekommunikation mit derselben Bandbreite und auch noch in annähernd Echtzeit, das heißt unmittelbar, wenn ihr was über die Datenleitung flirtscht, dann will der Staat das auch haben. Und die Überwachungsträger müssen auch noch, dass es in der Richtlinie wiederum festgesehen, gewisse Kapazitäten bereitstellen. Das heißt, dass ein gewisser Prozentsatz der Leute abgehört werden kann. Und was ganz wichtig ist, ist, es soll auch mehrfach Überwachung möglich sein. Also das heißt nicht, wenn man, wenn gegen einen ermittelt wird, wegen was weiß ich, einer Straftat jetzt durch die Polizei, sondern wenn gleichzeitig noch der Verfassungsschutz ein Auge auf euch geworfen hat oder der Bundesnachrichtendienst oder das Zollkriminalamt oder das Bundeskriminalamt, dann werdet ihr unter Umständen bis zu fünf, glaube ich, gleichzeitig sollen also in einer Lage sein, eure Telekommunikationen eben in annähernd gleicher Zeit in voller Bandbreite übermittelt zu bekommen. Und das kostet natürlich einen Haufen Kohle.
Das wird wahrscheinlich Kohle, es wird wahrscheinlich analog zum Kohle-Fenich, wird es dann irgendwann den Abhör-Fenich noch geben bleiben.
Genau, den Solidarbeitrag für die Dienste oder so, keine Ahnung.
Da gab es hier wohl so ein schönes Dokument irgendwie. Also es hätte fast Satire sein können, aber es ist leider echt von Siemens. Die bieten nämlich einen, wie nennt sich der, der, der Lawful Interception, das ist also der für die behördlich genehmigte Abhörmaßnahmen, ist es so der Fachbegriff. Und sie haben ein Betriebssystem, genau, sie haben ein Betriebssystem sozusagen, also einen Zusatz für ihre Vermittlungsstellen-Software bieten sie an. Das LIoS, also Lawful Interception Operating System, mit so netten Features, wie irgendwie...
Läuft das auch auf PowerPC?
Läuft auf den Vermittlungsstellen da und das liest sich so ganz toll in dieser Werbobroschüre so...
Das lustigste ist, dass in der Feature-Liste dann die beiden Kerneigenschaften so allererst stehen. Der erste Satz lautet, erfüllt strengste gesetzliche Anforderungen. Das klingt ja immerhin so, als würde man sich möglicherweise immerhin davor schützen wollen, dass vielleicht unberechtigt abgehört wird und der nächste Satz ist dann gleich flexibel, konfigurierbar.
Und wenn wir dieses Jahr keine Demokratie mehr haben, dann einen kleinen Patch einspielen oder eine kleine Konfiguration.
Zukunftskompatibel, um es nochmal für den Normalbenutzer zu übersetzen, was daran sozusagen so gravierend und eigentlich skandalös ist, ist das, was in Deutschland, da kann man ja noch sagen, wir haben immerhin noch eine Rechtsstaatsimulation. Da gibt es noch ein Grundgesetz, es gibt noch Behörden, die sich möglicherweise an Gesetze halten müssen. Selbst Politiker sollen sich mitunter Richtlinien gegenüber Gesetze sehen, an die sie sich halten müssen. Da ignorieren sie zwar auch mal, aber immerhin, es gibt sie. Und es gibt auch entsprechende parlamentarische Kontrollkommissionen beispielsweise beim Abhören. In anderen Ländern ist es halt so, da heißt gesetzmäßige Kommunikation. Der König eines afrikanischen Landes, da ist halt das Gesetz ihm Person. Und gesetzmäßiges Abhören heißt, er möchte gerne alle seine Bürger abhören. Oder die chinesische Regierung agiert da ähnlich. Und da Siemens diese EBSD-Technologie, das ist das elektronische Wehrsystem digital, weltweit verkauft, heißt es auch, dass in allen Ländern dieser Welt im Grunde genommen eben eine flexibel konfigurierbare und skalierbare Technologie zur Bewachung eingebaut ist auf gut deutsch diktaturkompatible Software. Einen kurzen Nachsatz wollte ich noch ergänzen, bevor wir den Hörer reinnehmen. Wäre dieses Dokument zur elektronischen Wehre-System digital dafür mal sieben mit dem Lawful Interception. Wer sich das mal reinziehen will und wissen will, was im Telefonsystem so alles nettes eingebaut ist, der findet das auf ftp.ccc.de. Und da irgendwie Siemens, Li, PDF oder irgendwas, das findet ihr dann schon.
Alles klar, dann nehmen wir jetzt den Hörer ein. Hallo Christoph.
Christoph?
Jo, ich bin jetzt dran, ja. Ich wollte mal meine Meinung sagen. Und zwar, ähm, ja, also ich finde das erstmal irgendwie kacke, weil, ich weiß nicht, erstmal fragt man sich, in welcher Zeit wir leben. Das kommt ja im Westen ja teilweise so vor. Obwohl ich davon nie betroffen gewesen bin, dass man ja wieder um 10, 15 Jahre zurückgeschleudert wird. Und an das Zweite ist, ja ich weiß nicht, also mir ist es halt auch schon so gegangen, dass ich in so eine Scheiße reingetappt bin. Und das ist auf jeden Fall äußerst unangenehm, wenn man dann auch danach merkt, dass seine Privatsphäre auch irgendwo arg eingeschränkt wurde. Und ja, ich weiß nicht, dahin übergreifend ist unsere ganze Drogenpolitik eigentlich überhaupt scheiße. Also ich meine, was wird denn hier getan? Also hier wird einfach nur was getan, um irgendwelche kleinen Leute, die im Grunde genommen eh keinen Plan haben, zu ficken und irgendwelche Zahlen zu schreiben. Und was kommt dabei raus? Nee, es wird halt weiter im Bundestag koks gezogen und sonst was für eine Scheiße. Oder irgendein EU-Scheißminister, der für Drogen verantwortlich ist.
Aber wir reden doch gerade gar nicht über Drogen.
Zieh nochmal kräftig.
Nee, das hängt damit aber zusammen einfach mal. Und das ist auch darauf bezogen, wie es mir gegangen ist. Und das kotzt mich einfach so tierisch an, weil das ist so eine riesen Super-Scheiße, was da abgezogen wird. Gelderverschwendung in all möglichen Orten. Also ich kann da echt nur sagen, nee danke. So was, ah nee, so was kotzt mich total an, wenn ich das hier höre.
Na die entsprechenden Maßnahmen sind ja keine verschwendeten.
Der Mann hat ja mit seiner Meinungsäußerung erstmal nicht unrecht. Ein weiser Mann hat mal gesagt, im Sozialismus beutet der Mensch den Menschen aus. Im Kapitalismus ist es genau umgekehrt. Also das Problem ist ja, wir reden hier natürlich auch ein Stück weit vom Teil eines Repressionsapparates, der eben dazu dient, ja, bestimmte Dinge zu kontrollieren.
Ja, aber toll, die kontrollieren so viel. Ich meine, was kommt im Endeffekt dabei raus? Also mal als Gegenfrage. Und ich glaube, das ist nie unbedingt der Superführer, weißt du?
Na ja, ich meine, wir haben ja hier auch noch, wir wollten heute in der Sendung auch noch darüber reden, wie man sich davor schützen kann, weil diese ganzen Überwachungsmaßnahmen, die sind natürlich ein bisschen besorgniserregend für diejenigen, die nicht wissen, wie man sich davor schützt. Aber wir haben ja Computer und Computer sind Werkzeuge, und damit können wir zum Beispiel unsere Telekommunikation verschlüsseln. Wir können auch zu den Werkzeugen von Binlading greifen, damit man nicht die Sprengstoffe und die Raketenelefanten, sondern Steganografie, das heißt eben das Verschleiern von Telekommunikation, sodass...
Ich nenne gut, okay, wenn man halbwegs anständig ist, hat man den Grund dazu, aber...
Das ist die Frage.
Das ist wirklich die große Frage.
Ich find's einfach scheiße. Die nächste Frage ist dann auch schon wieder, ob das auch dabei bleibt. Also ich kann mir fast nie vorstellen, dass dann bloß irgendwelche Leute davon betroffen sind. Also da wird dann halt mal vermutet und bei den Leuten, bei denen dann bloß eine Vermutung da ist, da klappt das dann vielleicht mit Abhören oder was auch immer für ein Scheiß.
Die Frage kann man eigentlich mit einer Gegenfrage beantworten und die lautet, ist es je bei irgendetwas einfach geblieben?
Ja, eher nein.
Christoph, danke für deinen Anruf.
Ja, alles klar.
Oh, der war sauer, mein lieber Herr Gesangsverein. Kann ich aber irgendwie nachvollziehen.
Es gibt einen schönen Text, was auch so die Geschichte der Überwachung angeht, nämlich von Detlef Nogala, der ist Kriminologe, glaube ich. Und da gibt es einen Text, der Frosch um heißen Wasser, der ist bei Heisel in Attilopolis erschienen. Und da erzählt er so ein bisschen wie eigentlich so die Überwachung, die Vorstellung der totalen Überwachung eigentlich schon so aus der abendländischen Kultur kommt. Und da gibt es dann so das christliche Bild des Allwissenden, weil alles sehnen Gott und die religiöse Variante einer umfassenden, prüfenden Beobachtung. Und da gibt es auch so dieses architektonisches Prinzip eines Panoptikums. Das ist also so wie so ein Gefängnis, wo die Werte drin in so einer übergeordneten Glaskuppel sitzen und irgendwie jeden in seiner Zelle beobachten können. Und allein dadurch entsteht schon dieser Druck, diese Repression, durch dieses Wissen allein jederzeit komplett kontrolliert zu werden. Und das ist irgendwie auch so ein ganz großes Problem, was wir natürlich auch mit Überwachungskameras haben, die jetzt überall kommen, weil da gibt es irgendwie Leute, die lassen sich freiwillig so rund drei Monate in so einem Container einsperren, mit überall filmen und dann verstehen irgendwie viele Leute auch gar nicht was an Überwachungskameras, irgendwie in Bahnhöfen, was so das Problem ist.
Diese Sendungen führen doch letztlich auch zu einer fürchterlichen Desensibilisierung der Bevölkerung.
Ja, natürlich.
Oh, hier ruft noch einer und vielleicht ist der auch sauer. Hier ist das Chaosradio. Wir brauchen hier dringend, also Chaosradio 58 hier, guten Abend, wir brauchen dringend Salzstangen, sonst bricht, also er bricht, Kollege Müller-Magun, sich ins Studio und das würde ich vermieden wissen wollen. Marlene Dietrich Allee 20 in Potsdam, bitte bringt Salzstangen, danke. Machen wir jetzt weiter? Mit was? Mit Salzstangen. Und Hürsen.
Und dann sind es Hürsen und Stangen.
Irgendetwas über das Cybercrime-Convention.
Wir wollen natürlich auch darüber reden, wie man sich davor schützen kann und hier nicht nur blöde, düstere Bilder malen. Aber wo wir gerade dabei sind, blöde, düstere Bilder zu malen, können wir ja noch mal kurz die anderen Mosaik-Bausteinchen aufziehen. Da gibt es zum Beispiel die Cybercrime-Convention.
Ist das so was wie die Star Trek-Convention?
Ja, das ist so ungefähr dasselbe, weil Star Trek ist ja wahrscheinlich auch so eine Bedrohung aus dem Weltall. In diesem Fall ist es eine Bedrohung von der anderen Seite des Atlantiks, von Amerika. Da hat die Industrie sich vor einiger Zeit was ausdenken lassen, das heißt der Digital Millennium Copyright Act. Und darunter ist jetzt nicht nur das übliche Verbot, nämlich kopieren, nicht lizenzierte Software und bla bla bla, sondern bereits die Verbreitung von Informationen zur Behebung von Urheberrechtsschutzmechanismen soll strafbar gemacht werden. Das heißt nur das Erklären von Technologie, wie Urheberrechtsschutz heute in unseren Computern realisiert wird und wie man ihnen gehen kann, soll dann bereits strafbar sein. Das führt zwar auch in Amerika zunächst einmal zu einer juristischen Auseinandersetzung mittlerweile größeren Ausmaßes, weil die haben ja noch so was wie Freedom of Speech oder den theoretisch verbrieften Antwort frei reden zu dürfen. Das hindert aber natürlich nicht die Europäische Union bzw. das Europäische Parlament, das gleich noch alles viel besser zu machen, auch weil wir ja keinen Verbrieft des Recht auf Freie Meinungsäußerung haben, zumindest was nicht Einschränkungen hat. Und ich weiß, ich hab zu vielleicht gerade Lust, diese Cybercrime-Gedünnen zu erklären, sonst...
Na ja, es gibt da eben wieder zwei Dinge, die so, es gibt eigentlich drei Dinge, die dem DMCA nicht entsprechen, aber genau dieses Schild abdecken und in dieses Schema passen, das zum einen eben das vorhin erwähnte, diese Pay-TV-Richtlinie, die Zugangskontroll um Gehmechanismen verbietet und in diesem Fall auch zum ersten Mal sogenannte vorbereitende Handlungen, also eben das Bereitstellen von Informationen über kommerzielle Kommunikationsnetze, was bedeutet, dass ein Web-Server sicherlich unter diese Richtlinie fallen wird. Zum anderen die Verschärfung des Urheberrechts durch das Europäische Parlament und die Stärkung der Position der rechte Inhaber oder in diesem Fall auch der Verwertungsgesellschaften, die sich ja positionieren als Vertreter der rechten Inhaber. Und schlussletztlich das Cybercrime-Abkommen, das die Verbreitung von Angriffswerkzeugen, sogenannten Hacker Tools, untersagt und unter Strah stellen möchte. Wobei auch hier wieder, wie im Pay-TV-Abkommen, die Frage ist, was ist ein Angriffswerkzeug, was ist eine illegale Vorrichtung? Und die Formulierung, die hier in der Regel gewählt wird, ist, jedes Gerät oder Computerprogramm, das dazu bestimmt oder angepasst ist, um die Überwindung ohne Erlaubnis des Diensteambiters zu ermöglichen. Hier im Fall jetzt in der Pay-TV-Richtlinie, im Fall des Cybercrime-Abkommens ist es ein Programm oder ein Gerät, was modifiziert werden kann oder speziell modifiziert ist, um Angriffe durchzuführen. Wobei hier ganz klar auch Programme zum Testen von Sicherheitsschwachstellen für Systemadministratoren drunter fallen und die werden nicht ausgenommen. Es gibt zwar inzwischen in einer Fußnote einen Hinweis, dass diese Tools legal bleiben für die Anwendung durch Systemadministratoren gegen ihre eigenen Systeme zum Aufdecken von Sicherheitslücken, was ja auch aller im Interesse von uns allen liegt. Aber in der Regel ist es so, dass sich eine drastische Verschiebung der Rechtssituation und der Rechtssicherheit auch bietet und dass die Regierungen deutlich stärkere Positionen besitzen, um beispielsweise Systeme zu beschlagnahmen oder Kommunikationszugänge zu erwarten.
Also diese Richtlinien, im Sinne dieses Abkommen, was da diskutiert wird, das soll eigentlich so den Status haben und das kommt auch so aus der Ecke, die normalerweise sowas wie die Menschenrechtskonvention machen. Und diese Konvention soll dann von den Staaten, die da jetzt mitarbeiten, unterzeichnet werden. Und mit dem Unterzeichnen, mit dem Ratifizieren dieses Abkommens verpflichten sich die Staaten, dieses Abkommen in das landeseigene Recht zu übernehmen. Das heißt, sie müssen ihre Gesetze entsprechend anpassen und entsprechend ändern, dass sie dieser Konvention genügen. Und das geht dann noch ein bisschen weiter. Das geht nicht nur dieses Verbot, sondern es geht dann auch zu Sachen, wie sind, welche Maßnahmen dürfen oder müssen ergriffen werden, welche Amtshilfe gibt es der Länder untereinander. Und da sind dann so kleine Feinheiten drin, wie zum Beispiel, also da gab es ein bisschen Streit um den Punkt, dass ein Land von einem anderen Land eine Maßnahme, eine Rechtshilfe-Maßnahme fordern kann, auch wenn diese Maßnahme als solche in diesem Land irgendwie nicht vorgesehen ist oder nicht bekannt ist. Also im schlimmsten Fall wäre es so, wenn die Amerikaner fordern, dass jemand hier in Deutschland hingerichtet werden soll, weil die das so gerne hätten. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es so zu verstehen ist, aber so kam es auf jeden Fall über dieses Thema.
Das bezieht sich insbesondere auf Rechtshilfe, sozusagen für den Fall, dass die Straftaten in dem anderen Land nicht vorhanden sind. Also nehmen wir an, Land A verbietet, was weiß ich, pornografische Bilder und Land B tut es nicht. Und ein Bürger von Land B verbreitet diese Sachen und Land A will jetzt irgendwie Rechtshilfe. Wir haben ja auch in Frankreich, wir haben auch in Australien, wir haben ja ein Bundesgerichtshof-Burteil, das jetzt auch erfasst hat, dass eben ein australischer Strafbürger sich strafbar macht, wenn er nach deutschem Recht sich strafbar macht. Also wir sagen, wenn er den Holocaust leugnet und das in australische Strafbürger, kann er sich trotzdem des Verstosses an deutschen Gesetze strafbar machen und entsprechende Schritte werden dann eingeleitet. Also andersrum heißt das, wenn man jetzt nach China einreist, als Studenten man vielleicht bei der Einreise gleich erschossen wird, weil es könnte ja sein, dass die chinesische Regierung dann ihrerseits ihre Rechtsempfindlichkeiten eben auch auf die Bürgeranrauschdaten ausdehnt und das wäre so ein bisschen blöd, weil das hieße, dass das, was wir im Netz haben, diese Informationsfreiheit zur Bewegungseinschränkung im wirklichen Leben führt, wäre so ein bisschen eingeschränkt geschickt.
Wenn offizieller Medienpartner der Echo Verleihung 2001 dann frisst. Das Wetter, nachts kaum noch Schnee bei minus 5 bis minus 10 Grad. Morgen dann anfangs trüb. Später Aufheiterung bei minus 1 bis plus 2 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Jörg Poppen.
Die israelische Arbeitspartei hat sich am Abend für eine Regierungsbeteiligung entschieden. An der Abstimmung über eine Koalition mit dem Liquidblock des gewählten Ministerpräsidenten Sharon nahm in weniger als die Hälfte der Delegierten teil. Für das Parteienbündnis hatte vor allem Friedensnobelpreisträger Perez geworden, der als künftiger Außenminister im Gespräch ist. In Bonn hat sich der zentrale Krisenstab des Bundesverbraucherministeriums auf ein 6-Punkte-Programm gegen die Maul- und Clown-Seuche verständigt. In Großbritannien wurden unter das Fälle der Seuche bekannt. Die Europäische Union öffnet ihre Märkte für Produkte aus der Dritten Welt. Die EU-Außenminister billigten in Brüssel gegen den Willen, in Frankreich seine entsprechende Vorlage der EU-Kommission. Die Zollbeschränkungen sollen langsam liberalisiert und bis zum Jahr 2009 völlig abgeschafft werden. Im Fall der verschwundenen Ulrike aus Eberswalde ist der Fahrer eines weißen Pkw tatverdächtig. Nach dem etwa 20 bis 30 Jahre alten 1, 75 m großen Mann werde bundesweit gefahren, das sagte heute ein Polizeisprecher. Beim Abgang einer Lawine in der Zugspitze ist heute eine Frau ums Leben gekommen. Sie erlag in einem Krankenhaus ihren Verletzungen. Zwei weitere Personen konnten sich aus eigener Kraft aus der Lawine befreien. Der Verkehr A13 Dresden Schönefelder Kreuz zwischen Kittlitz und Spreewald behindert ein Defekt des Fahrzeugs, den Verkehrs kommt zum Stau und im Landkreis Spree neisse Verkehrsbehinderungen wegen Nebels. Die Sichtweite beträgt unter 30 Meter, also Fuß vom Gas.
Vielen Dank. Fritz präsentiert die Echo-Verleihung 2001 und Fritz verleiht den Berliner Nachwuchspreis für nationale Popmusik, den Fritz Echo und die Nominierten sind Sportfreunde Stiller, Dynamite Dillard, Lexi und Kay Paul, Paula und D-Flame. Wer den Fritz Echo bekommt, entscheidet hier per Voting unter www.tvmovie.de oder per SMS. 0170 902 65 08 Echo 2001 15. März im ITC Berlin. Nur echt mit Echo.
Die Programmzeitschrift mit dem roten Moviestar.
Du hast Chaosradio 58 auf, Fritz, schönen guten Abend. 23.37 für die Uhrzeitfetischisten unter euch. Ähm, wer uns...
Warum wollt ihr eigentlich, ja genau...
Ob wir den Staat abschaffen, ob wir die Geheimdienste abschaffen oder ist das alles verschlüsselt?
Genau, wo für den Brauch man eigentlich Geheimdienste? Wie verschlüsselt ihr? Was macht ihr? Fühlt ihr euch sicher? Also ich meine, wenn ihr die nicht immer dieses subtile Gefühl habt, sondern ob sie noch drei Leute nach dem sich Toten...
Glaubt ihr, dass die Stasi aufgelöst ist? Oder ist es vielleicht alles gar nicht so schlimm? Also ich meine, habt ihr... Verschlüsselt ihr nicht, weil ihr nichts zu verbergen habt?
Glaubt ihr, dass es Luft hier atmet?
Wie die Nummer?
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Eure Meinung zu Überwachung und Verschlüsselung beziehungsweise Überwachung und Schutz vor eben jener?
Das kann gar nicht sein, aber egal.
Dann schalte ich den Stream einfach ab.
Ja, das wäre gut. Pass auf, zum Thema, ich hätte ein paar technische Fragen, ob es sich denn lohnt, irgendwie mal kurz drüber schwätzen.
Lohnt sich, fang doch mal an.
Ja, okay. Folgendes Ding. Gibt es technische Möglichkeiten momentan anonym durchs Netz zu surfen? Also ich hätte ein paar Ideen, allerdings. Ähm, gibt's ja, also ich gibt ja diese Pre-Net-Geschichte. Also, ähm, bin ich jetzt live ein Herr, oder was? Ich dachte, ich hab erst mal ein lecker Vorgespräch. Nix gewiss. Dann mal los. Okay, anonym durchs Netz. Ihr habt ja die ganze Zeit theoretisch geredet. Schön philosophisch, wie das denn im Background so läuft. Aber jetzt mal technisch. Gibt's eine Möglichkeit, die letzte Meile zu überbrücken, wo alles kann überbrüht werden? Die Telekom hat das jetzt um ein halbes Jahr hochgesetzt. Ist das richtig?
Das ist richtig.
Also nicht die Telekom, sondern der Gesetzgeber hat erlaubt, dass es jetzt so ist. Genau.
Nicht nur erlaubt, sondern sogar erlaubt.
Er hat Mindestspeicherungsfristen definiert. Bisher gab es nur Höchstspeicherungsfristen.
Gibt's eine Möglichkeit, also ich meine, Freenet oder solche Geschichten von SourceForge, da gibt's ja die Möglichkeit, nach der letzten Meile zum Provider das ganze Ding zu anonymisieren. Mehr oder Minder.
Also redest du jetzt von der Verbindung, also wenn du dich einwählst irgendwo, dann ist der Datensatz erstmal da. Das heißt, die wissen erstmal, du hast dich irgendwo eingewählt. Und dann machst du irgendwas so. Dann rufst du vielleicht einen anonymen Remailer auf, der aufgerufen wird.
Genau. Und die Frage ist jetzt, ob es technische Lösungen gibt, um das zu umgehen.
Ja klar, du kannst einfach alles verschlüsseln. Die ganze Kommunikation, da gibt's dann so Technologien wie IPsec zum Beispiel.
Ja, aber du kannst nicht umgehen, dass der Provider ein Lockfile schweilt.
Der Provider hat ein Lockfile, egal ob das...
Ja gut, er hat halt irgendwie ein Lockfile, wo drin steht, irgendwie drei Stunden lang Grauschen auf IP-Adresse, so und so, so und so.
Naja, das sind halt zwei grundsätzliche Punkte. Zum einen hast du die Inhalte und du hast die Metadaten, die Verbindungsdaten der Kommunikation.
Die Verbindungsdaten der Kommunikation, die inhalten da aber auch HTTP irgendwas oder HTTP.
Nein, nein.
Nein, das sind Inhaltsdaten, würde ich sagen.
Also nach der Tabel Kommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung hat der Hörer Recht und diese Begleitumstände der Telekommunikation, das Aufrufen einer Webseite.
So und das Problem ist ja, dass sowohl E-Mail als auch Webseiten und so weiter, ich meine, es hat einfach niemandem was anzugehen, wenn ich da was ich auch immer anschaue. Und theoretisch ist es ja möglich mit Proxies, Mix-Proxies, was der Geier, was da gerade alles noch probiert wird, das alles nach dem Provider zu verschlüsseln oder dem Besitzer in einer Webseite zu verschlüsseln, woher ich komme, aber nicht zu verschlüsseln bei meinem Provider, wer ich war und was ich gemacht habe.
Wobei du musst also nochmal unterscheiden zwischen der Abhörmaßnahme in Echtzeit sozusagen und der nachträglichen Auswertung der Lockfights. Also das ist natürlich so eine Echtzeitüberwachung, die gibt irgendwie deutlich mehr Möglichkeiten, Daten zu sammeln und zu kontrollieren.
Das ist aber auch viel aufwendiger.
Ja, die einzige Methode, dich davor zu schützen, besteht de facto da drin, einen Telekommunikationsassistent, einen Provider, auf gut Deutsch zu wählen, der das, was er da tut, nicht unter den gesetzlichen Anforderungen tut. Das mag beispielsweise im universitären Bereich beispielsweise der Fall sein, weil das keine...
Und Universitäten nicht auch am Ende zu verpflichtet, wie gewerbliche Provider die Daten zu schmeißen?
Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht, weil es kein geschäftsmäßiges Erbringen von Telekommunikation ist. Allerdings ab nach bestimmten Grüße von Benutzern sind sie wieder drin. Im aktuellen Entwurf gibt es da zwei Paragraphen, die ich jetzt leider nicht im Kopf habe. Aber die kannst du selber unter www.iu.kdg dir da irgendwo runterladen.
Dann schau ich gleich mal um.
Und de facto kann ich dir also bei Commerz-ISPs keine Chance sehen.
Gab es? Ich hab zwischendurch was gehört von Providern, die ausdrücklich anonyme Zugänge anbieten. Was ist das?
Ja, was heißt anonyme? Das heißt, dass du eventuell ohne dort mit deinen Daten registriert bist?
Das ist aber Quatsch, weil in dem Moment, wo du den Telefonhörer abnimmst, bist du da registriert.
Ja, das mag sein. Aber die Live-Abhörungen lässt sich damit ja nicht umgehen. Aber ich habe gehört von Providern, die anbieten, also ISPs, dass du einen Zugang bekommst und nicht mitgelockt wird, ausdrücklich gegen hohe Gebühren oder was. Keine Ahnung, wie das lief.
Gibt es das?
Habt ihr davon was gehört?
Einzig, was mir gerade anfühlen würde, ist Zero Knowledge Systems, eine kanadische Firma hat ein Produkt entwickelt namens Freedom, basiert auf einem Set von Mixed-Proxies, die tatsächlich auch funktionieren. Allerdings gibt es den Client derzeit nur für Windows, ich glaube auch nur für die Windows 9X-Serie.
Da dürfte ich gerade mal eine dämliche Zwischenfrage stellen, was ist Mixed-Proxies?
Das sind Computer, die auf den Verbindungswege eingeschleift werden und Proxies sind stellvertretend für dich Kommunikations-Dienstleistungen erbringen, d.h. dieser Computer ist im Falle einer Website oder dafür zuständig, die Website vom Betreiber anzufordern und sie dir weiterzuleiten. Das Konzept dabei ist aber nicht, dass es nur ein Computer tut, sondern es sind viele, d.h. es werden von vielen Computern Zugriffe auf einen Host durchgeführt, die jeweils nur Teile des Kommunikationsangebots laden und mir diese Möglichkeit nicht zu sehen, sondern sieht nur dieses Netz von Proxies, nachdem es aber sehr viele User in der Theorie nutzen, ist nicht mehr ersichtlich, dass ich diese Telekommunikationsdienstleistungen in Anspruch genommen habe. Des Weiteren ist der Vorteil, dass zwischen mir und diesem Proxynetz in der Regel verschlüsselt kommuniziert wird, d.h. dass die einzigen Verbindungsdaten, die anfallen, eine permanente Verbindung zwischen mir und einem Netz von verschlüsselten Proxies...
Das ist ja dieses straffende Rauschen, was da kommt.
Damit lässt sich ja ganz einfach umgehen, dass niemand vor und hinter dem Proxy lauschen kann und an Hand der Zugriffszeiten feststellen kann, wer was aufgerufen hat.
Genau, wenn du diesem Proxy, diesem Dienst traust, dass der seine Arbeit gut macht und eben nicht irgendwie vom Geheimdienst oder wandert ist, dann ist das bestimmt eine gute Sache.
Ja, Vertrauen spielt da eine große Rolle. Mal noch eine weitere Frage. Idee, ein wireless LAN, die jetzt anfangen, meinetwegen auf Community-Base zu sagen, okay, wir scheren... So, was ist, wenn innerhalb dieses Lans, was weiß ich, ein paar Mix-Proxies am Laufen sind, die beide in den Buden von den ganzen Leuten laufen, und meines Weges jetzt zehn DSL-Zugänge freigegeben sind, und über diese DSL-Zugänge, das gerautet wird, in keinem regelmäßigen, mit einem votierenden Skript oder was, keine Ahnung, und es finden beispielsweise illegale Zugriffe statt, DOS...
Dann ist es kein Problem, denn wir werden einfach bei 21 Leuten die Wohnung durchsucht. Denn wir werden einfach bei 21 Leuten die Wohnung durchsucht.
Ja, aber haften können doch am Ende nicht alle.
Bitte?
Haften können doch am Ende nicht alle. Ich meine, du kriegst einfach ein Problem, wenn du sagst, okay, wir möchten das machen. Es gibt eine Gruppe von Leuten, die sich die Dinge zu fahren. Aber es besteht ja die eklatante Gefahr, dass ein wireless Laden nicht sicher ist und sich jemand einloggt drauf, der das nicht darf.
Das ist aber eine Frage der Beweiserbringung. Und zwar ist es in der Regel so, dass du diesen Beweis nicht führen musst deiner Unschuld, sondern es ist dir der Beweis deiner Schuld erbracht werden muss.
Das ist immer wieder in Deutschland.
Die Frage ist nur nach der geschäftsmäßigen Erbringung von Telekommunikationsdiensten. Naja, sofern du ein rechtliches Konstrukt, wie beispielsweise ein Verein, hinbekommst, diese Dienstleistung zu erbringen für seine Mitglieder und es als Mitglieder interne Kommunikation stattfindet und in diesem Netz einen Übergang in planetenweite Datennetze wie dem Internet stattfindet, dann ist nur die Frage, wer übernimmt die Haftung für diesen Übergang. Das ist in der Regel dann der Verein als Betreiber. Und hier ist die Frage, wie weit von seinen Mitgliedern trennen, wie weit ist es möglich, da eine Beweis erhebliche Datenmenge speichern zu müssen oder eben nicht?
Also meinst du, das ganze Ding muss dann schon über den Verein laufen?
Naja, da gibt es irgendwie auch eine interessante Sache. In dieser Cybercrime-Convention ist nämlich diese Art Kollektivhaftung sozusagen auch vorgesehen. Hier ist erstmal nur von Firmen die Rede, aber da geht es darum, dass letztendlich irgendwie der Chef der Firma sozusagen dafür verantwortlich ist, was auch über den Internetzugang seiner Firma passiert. Also so sinngemäß. Es kann sich noch was geändert haben.
Ich erinnere mich jetzt auch, dass das ja auch vorlich ist, das ist ja ein Entwurf. Genau.
Und die Kollektivhaftung werden sie auch in Deutschland wohl so erstmal nicht so einfach durchkriegen.
Ja, das wäre die umgekehrte Beweislast, alle sind schuldig, es sei denn, sie beweisen ihre Unschuld.
Das sind so ein paar ja quasi unmögliche.
Also prinzipiell ist die...
Aber es gibt Staaten, die machen das.
Ja, die Amis da sind ja da ganz rigoros, glaube ich, ja?
Ja, die Chinesen haben da auch so ihre Eigenlagen.
Oh ja, die Chinesen und ihre Provider, ja ja, aber der Typ, der am Schluss an seinem DSL-Anschluss sitzt, der kann doch im Endeffekt, mal logisch überlegt, nicht haftbar gemacht werden, nach deutscher Gesetzgebung. Wenn er sagen kann, ok, ich hab hier ein Netzwerk hinter mir hängen und ich bin ja gar nicht...
Es gibt ja den Punkt der Beihilfe.
Schwannerei.
Also es gibt den Punkt der Beihilfe zu Straftaten und die Frage ist, ob der in diesem Fall greift, das heißt, man müsste sich tatsächlich ein juristisches Konstrukt überlegen, wie ein Verein und eine Person, die diese Haftung übernimmt und für ihre Mitglieder diese Dienstleistung in Anspruch nimmt. Das hat wohl bisher noch niemand gemacht, ich würde dir viel Glück wünschen.
Also ich werde eventuell noch mal Kontakt mit euch aufnehmen.
Ja, haltet uns auf dem Laufen. Wir können bei der Gelegenheit auch mal unsere Mail-Adresse durchsagen, das ist da heraus, Radioette, ccc.de.
Wohnst du in Berlin?
Nee, Weimar.
Weimar, das ist ein bisschen weit weg. Aber du hast bestimmt irgendwie Platz auf dem Dach, wo du eine Antenne aufstellen kannst.
Und die 2, 4 Gigahertz sind für alle frei. Genau. Okay, ich wünsche euch noch viel Spaß bei der Sendung.
Ja, wenn ihr noch Fragen habt oder uns erzählen wollt, wie ihr euch schützt davor, was denn da geplant ist und auch teilweise schon durchgeführt wird an Überwachungen, dann rufen wir es doch einfach mal an. Und wenn es lange klingelt, dann lasst es einfach lange klingeln, weil wir gehen hier direkt ran.
Neuer, was wir hier machen, ihr seid irgendwie braven Bürgerinnen und Bürger, ich kann mal ruhig abhören und ihr seht das alles gar nicht so. Ich rufe uns auch dann an, bitte. Vielen Dank.
Chaosradio 58 mit den ganzen Abgehörten. Und Oskar ist am Telefon. Hallo Oskar.
Hallo, grüß euch, wünsch euch einen wunderschönen guten Abend. Und ich wollte einfach auch einen Moment Senf dazu abgeben, nämlich ich find's eigentlich Quatsch, dass die Regierung halt beschließt, jetzt alle abzuhören, weil ich denk Deutschland hat im Moment andere Probleme, als jetzt die kleinen Mann einfach so abzuhören.
Was sind so für andere Probleme?
Zum Beispiel von wegen Rechtsradikalismus, dass man sich halt da die Leute raussucht, die dann halt abgehört werden sollten.
Ja, aber das ist doch ganz prima, die abzuhören, oder?
Na ja, nur das.
Oder geht denn für die Anderes Recht, wie für alle anderen, wie zum Beispiel Linksextremisten?
Ja, nur dann denke ich, äh, das ist doch die Polizei, oder?
So zusammen mit der Begründung, einige wenige Teilnehmer unserer Gesellschaft halten sich nicht an die Gesetze, benehmen sich nicht anständig und so weiter und so fort. Ein Apparat geschaffen wird, der letztendlich das Zeug dazu hat, die Demokratie in eine Diktatur zu verwandeln. Insofern ist das schon eine grundsätzliche Frage, ob man das okay findet oder nicht. Also deswegen mit Rechtsradikalen, die auch noch abzuhören. Ich weiß nicht, ob man denen sozialen so viel Gehör schenken sollte oder ob man sie nicht eher mal fragen sollte, wie sie sich gesellschaftlich sinnvoll einbringen können, anstelle von irgendwelchen Blödsinn zu machen. Ich meine, das ist letztendlich eine gesellschaftliche Diskussion, die in eine ganz andere Richtung geht, die aber eigentlich geführt werden muss, weil es nütztet, wenn du die abhörst.
Ja, naja, dann noch eine Frage an euch.
Ja, und jetzt meine Frage ist, welche anderen Firmen planen jetzt eine Flatrate oder haben eine Flatrate am Laufen?
Ich glaube, eine Flatrate ist immer so ein bisschen so ein Problem, weil eine Flatrate immer eine Mischkalkulation ist. Das heißt, die gehen davon aus, dass die Leute denn doch schon nicht so viel surfen werden. Und das hat sich bisher jedes Mal irgendwie als Trugschluss raus, weil das ist natürlich das Erste, was die Leute gemacht haben, ist die Verbindung aufgebaut und sie erst wieder abgebaut, als der Anschluss dann wieder gekündigt wurde bzw. die Firma pleite war. Und das rechnet sich alles nicht wirklich so. Das heißt, die Firmen müssen halt irgendwie da was Gescheites anbieten. Aber wir wollen heute auch eigentlich gar nicht so viel über Flatrates. Das war vorhin nur so ein Eingriff.
Ich habe vorhin eingeschaltet und da habt ihr irgendwas von dieser Aqua Flatrate erzählt.
Ja, guck mal, vielleicht so www.teltarif.de oder sowas. Die machen da immer ganz hübsche Listen und sind auch immer aktuell.
Und was würde denn mit Leuten passieren, die dann halt, weiß ich was, sich Programme saugen, die man sich eigentlich nicht saugen dürfte aus dem Internet? Und wenn sowas dann rauskommt oder zählt das gar nicht dazu, zu diesen Abhörgeschichten?
Naja, also erstmal ist natürlich der dran, der die Sachen anbietet. Und macht so ein Download. So und dann geht's natürlich weiter, dann gucken die sich vielleicht an, wer hat denn die Sachen alles gedownloadet, so wie das jetzt bei Napster auch passiert. Also da gab's so eine Meldung aus Belgien, ich weiß nicht, hat sich aber glaube ich als Ente erwiesen, dass der irgendwie bei Napster...
Das war eine Ente.
Das war eine Ente. Na gut. Also das ist aber schon zu befürchten, dass die sich dann auch angucken, wer lädt denn die Sachen da alle runter. Und dann da auch zu den Leuten hingehen.
Und was könnte das mit Konsequenzen haben?
Ich krieg so wenig Besuch, keine Ahnung.
Ja, ich krieg wenig Besuch, genau.
Immer schön morgens ab sieben Kaffee und Brötchen bereithalten. Wir danken an dieser Stelle für deinen Anruf. Wir kokseln nicht, um Himmels willen. Wir haben ja keine Salzstangen, das ist ja Andis Problem gerade, der fällt doch gleich um, glaube ich.
Danke für deinen Anruf.
Tschüss. Unsere Nummer hier beim Chaosradio.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Wer ist denn da dran?
Na, ich hab eine Frage, können Sie mich zurückrufen?
Ne, du bist jetzt gerade an R, also entweder sprichst du jetzt.
Was war denn das? Hallo, hier ist das Chaosradio.
Ja, hier ist Koks, hier ist Koks, wo ist Eber? Hallo?
Kannst du ein bisschen lauter sprechen? Du kommst ganz, ganz leise nur an.
Ich bin auf dem Telefon, wieder mal, Moment. Ja, wie ist das eigentlich?
Wir verstehen dich quasi gar nicht. Gib mal ein bisschen mehr Druck auf deine Stimme vielleicht.
Moment, ich... Ja, gut, okay, dann gehts jetzt also. Also, das Problem mit dem Abhören hatten wir hier schon 40 Jahre lang. Denn Stavik ist ja eigentlich allen noch ein Begriff. Das heißt aber nicht, dass jemand hier unrechte Dinge machen will. Bloß, wie gesagt, wenn jemand halt mal angenommen sowas treibt, dann hätte ich ja nichts dagegen, dass eben dort einer ist, der dem dann halt auf die Mütze haut. Bloß die, sagen wir mal, unbescholtenen Bürger sollten doch eigentlich vor sowas sicher sein.
Richtig. Interessanterweise hat Deutschland die höchste Anzahl von Abhörmaßnahmen.
Und zwar relativ, nicht absolut.
Genau.
Wie gesagt, nichts dagegen, wenn jemand ihn auf die Mütze kriegt, der eben kriminelle Sachen veranstaltet. Bloß, wie gesagt, man sollte vielleicht auch sich überlegen, ob man da nicht irgendwie Programme macht, die eben gewisse Sachen verhindern in der Planung.
Inwiefern jetzt verhindern?
Ich meine, es gibt ja für alles mögliche Computerprogramme. Warum sollte es nicht auch irgendwelche Sicherungen geben, die im PC schon automatisch eingebaut werden, um eben gewisse Sachen zu verhindern? Zum Beispiel das Hacken auf PTV-Geschichten. Da gibt es ja Programme, die es möglich machen, Premiere zu gucken, ohne dass man dafür bezahlt.
Also du meinst, mein Computer soll mir schon verbieten, dass ich zum Beispiel Kinderpornografie runterlade, dass ich einen Hacker-Tool im weitesten Sinne benutze? Also der Computer soll es erkennen, was ich mache?
Direkt kriminelle Sachen, Kinderpornografie, also da sollte es schon Möglichkeiten geben, dass sowas überhaupt verhindert wird.
Aber wer legt denn fest, welche Sachen das sind, deiner Meinung nach?
Gute Frage. Also alles das, was der Moral und eben dem Anstand widerspricht.
Der katholischen Kirche?
Das ist die katholische Kirche, die hab ich nicht legitimiert und ich möchte bitte nicht, dass die katholische Kirche, weil sie nämlich nicht legitimiert ist, mir sagt, was ich zu tun und zu lassen habe.
Vor allem was moralisch ist.
Wer redet hierbei moralisch von der katholischen Kirche?
Na ja, die katholische Kirche selbst.
Meine Schwester sagt immer, die soziale Marktwirtschaft ist genauso sozial, wie die katholische Kirche christlich ist. Also die katholische Kirche steht nicht zur Disposition.
Na ja, aber zum Beispiel sitzt die katholische Kirche in so einem Gremium wie dem Rundfunkrat und überwacht, was wir hier gerade reden. Und wenn das der katholischen Kirche nicht passt, dann wird die katholische Kirche sich beschweren.
Das mag sein, bloß die katholische Kirche steht nicht zur Disposition. Die sind genauso unmoralisch. Wenn ich mir überlege, was die ganzen Priester und Paffen oder diese sich alle schimpfen, da treiben, dass die dann nicht mehr aus der Kirche rausgeschmissen werden, also stehen die doch gar nicht zur Disposition.
Wer macht denn eigentlich all diese Fotos?
Aber ein Interessantes...
Nicht sagen, sonst kriegen wir Ärger.
Irgendwelche kranken Perverslinge, denen man eigentlich was abschneiden soll.
Das Problem ist zum Beispiel bei Kinderpornografie, dass die Amerikaner, das ist auch wieder ein Diskussionspunkt bei dieser Cybercrime-Convention gewesen, andere Vorstellungen haben von dem, was Kinderpornografie ist. Weil nach der amerikanischen Vorstellung ist es zum Beispiel eine erwachsene Frau, die abgebildet ist, wo drunter steht Naked Teens, also irgendwie minderjährig, dass das schon verboten ist. Weil da wird behauptet, es ist minderjährig und deswegen ist es Kinderpornografie.
Wenn da unter dem Bild so was drunter steht, dann gehört demjenigen, der das auf Blödheit drunterschreibt, auf den Deckel.
Vielleicht könnten wir uns von diesem Thema in Kong vielleicht Pornografie lösen. Das Problem ist ja, wer ist verantwortlich für die Klassifizierung von Informationen? Wer ist verantwortlich, falls das falsch geschieht, falls das bewusst falsch geschieht, was passiert, wenn ich im guten Glauben etwas tue, was sich im Nachhinein als Straftat oder als Straft bewährt, es gut entpuppt? Und wie ist das über Landesgrenzen hinweg? Die Frage der Meinungsfreiheit. Darf ich denn interne Dokumente, beispielsweise der Church of Scientology, ins Netz stellen? Darf ich das nicht unterliegen, dass in Deutschland würde man sagen, dies unterliegt noch der Meinungsäußerung über eine Form von Verfreihheit? Oder der Pressefreiheit. Während es in den USA eben die komplett entgegengesetzte Richtung ist, dass dort behauptet wird, diese Informationen seien Intellectual Property, geistiges Eigentum dieser Sekte. Und wir sprechen hier von dem Problem, dass sich eben durch die zunehmende Technisierung und durch die Kommunikationsverhältnisse eine Globalisierung ergibt. Und die Frage ist, wie weit möchte ich, dass fremde Demokratien seien es Demokratien seien es Nicht-Demokratien. Bei den Chinesen hätte ich es noch viel weniger gerne. Wie weit dürfen sich die erreisten, über mich zu urteilen, über mich zu herrschen?
Es geht nicht um das Urteilen als solches. Ich meine, jeder Mensch muss schon wissen, was er tut. Bloß, wenn er etwas Kriminelles treibt, muss er ihn auf den Deckel kriegen. Da ist es in dem Fall...
Ich glaube, das ist die Definition von kriminellen Handlungen.
Ja, ganz einfach kriminelle Handlungen, wie es eben jedes normale Strafgesetzbuch sagt. Ich meine, kriminell ist kriminell.
Das heißt, wenn ich den Namen eines Mitarbeiters eines Nachrichtendienstes nenne, dass es eine Straftat? Nach chinesischem Recht? Warum sollte das in Deutschland gelten?
Das Problem ist, dass wir nicht mehr national denken können in dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Es gibt eine ganz einfache Lösung. Auch wenn man nicht von Kirche hilft, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass das älteste Buch der Menschheit sagt, dies und jenes und jenes ist eben in Ordnung und dies und jenes nicht, dann sollte man sich vielleicht daran halten.
Warum?
Legitimiert?
Du redest jetzt von der Bibel. Und was ist zum Beispiel mit dem Koran?
Koran ist eindeutig nicht ganz so alt wie die Bibel.
Na gut, die Mara Parata ist eindeutig wesentlich älter als die Bibel. Datenkonsens zu finden, dürfte vergleichsweise schwierig sein.
Sagt euch Gandhi was, der Name? Mahatma Gandhi?
Ja, aber es kann ja durchaus sein, dass ich mit Mahatma Gandhi's Ansichten nicht einverstanden bin. Warum sollte also das für ihn gilt, für mich gelten?
Also der Mann hatte im britischen Vize damals Folgendes gesagt, wenn sich ihr Volk und mein Volk auf Grundlage der Lehren Jesu auf der Bergpredig zusammenkommen würden, das heißt, wenn sie sich alle dran halten würden, dann würde es unseren Völkern und der ganzen Welt besser gehen. Und es will doch wohl keiner bestreiten.
Und ich behaupte jetzt der Mann hat nicht recht.
Es würde doch wohl keiner bestreiten, dass die Menschen, wenn sie sich daran halten würden, wirklich besser leben würden.
Na ja, das will ich schon.
Ich glaube, dann wären die ganzen Diskussionen über Kriminalität doch eigentlich erledigt.
Richtig, wenn alle anarchie wollen, dann funktioniert es ja auch.
Ja, wobei das dann mit Rücksicht zu tun hätte. Und das ist was, was wiederum nicht funktioniert. Ich danke an dieser Stelle mal für deinen Anruf. Wir haben noch ein paar andere Erleiter. Apropos Anrufleitung, das hat mit der Uhrzeit gar nichts zu tun. Ja das Problem Hier ist das Chaosradio 48, wir reden über Überwachung und Überwachter und sagt ihr das doch mal, warum sage ich das denn immer?
Reale Gesetze gegen virtuelle Struktur.
Wie überwacht ihr eigentlich die Überwacher, die uns überwachen?
Genau, das würde uns doch jetzt mal interessieren. Wie überwacht ihr eigentlich die Überwacher, die euch überwachen? Hier ist unsere Nummer zum Handel.
0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110.
Wie gesagt, wir hängen keinen in die Warteschleife, das heißt, wenn ihr lange auf ein Freizeichen hört und wartet, dass jemand rangeht, dann ist das richtig. So bleibt einfach in der Leitung. Hier ist Chaosradio. Machst du bitte dein Radio aus vorher?
Ja, also ich finde, dass mein Vorgänger gesagt hat, dass ist sehr mit Vorsicht zu genießen. Also das finde ich sehr subjektiv, ja. Weil, ja wie gesagt, also das kann jeder halt verschiedene Ansichten haben und man kann die andere Ansicht aufzwingen. Aber das ist mit dieser Abhörung, das finde ich auch sehr, sehr, sehr mit Vorsicht zu genießen. Weil ich bin der Meinung, dass in Deutschland viel zu viel abgehört wird, ja. Und ich habe auch schon ein paar Beispiele aus meinem Bekanntenkreis praktisch, dass Leute abgehört wurden, die, sage ich mal, nicht schwer kriminell waren, sondern die, weiss ich jetzt irgendwie, ging es um Haschisch oder ging es um Graffiti-Sachen, finde ich, geht einfach ein bisschen zu weit. Also wenn es wirklich Leute sind, die den Staat gefährden und auch irgendwie andere Menschen gefährden, kann man das überlegen, aber die Frage ist, wer kontrolliert das?
Das ist eben genau der Punkt der Verhältnismäßigkeit der Mittel. Es ist schön, dass das mal ein Hörer anspricht. Wir hatten das auch noch als Hörerfrage vor später. Diese völlig neue Qualität, die durch automatisierte Überwachungsstellen stattfindet, dass eben keine Einzelfallprüfungen mehr stattfinden muss, zwingend, dass eine umfassende Überwachung technisch möglich wird und das relativ leicht durch die Änderung von Softwarerichtlinien, also wie Andi vorher schon erwähnte, durch die Änderung von Einstellungen im Betriebssystem, es jederzeit möglich ist, diese Systeme flexibel zu konfigurieren, weg von dem, was sich in einer Demokratie als Konsens, Einzelner, ist zu einem vollständigen Überwachungsstatten. Diese Drohungen abzuwenden, ist halt auch wichtig, und das aber zu erkennen, ist ein Prozess. Und die Frage ist eben, wie weit wird beispielsweise durch Sendungen wie Big Brother diese Sensibilität genommen, wie weit gewöhnt man sich daran ist, dieses berühmte Frosch im heißen Wasser?
Ja, aber ich meine, dass die Bevölkerung, dass die Bevölkerung der breiten Masse gar nicht so bewusst ist. Man wird auch immer argumentiert irgendwie mit Lauschangriff und wir wollen euch ja als euer Volker schützen, Polizeifrauen und Helfer und so weiter, ja. Und der Bevölkerung wird so ein bisschen Angst gemacht, dass sie praktisch, sag ich mal, gar nichts dagegen haben, dass sie überwacht werden. Also sie gefahrt sich einfach dabei, ja. Dass irgendwie gesagt wird, ja, und wir schützen euch ja vor den Hochkriminellen und so weiter. Ja, aber dass es dann eben weit übers Ziel hinausgeht. Und wir so ein bisschen in Richtung Stasi und das finde ich sehr gefährlich.
Ja, es ist sicherlich eine gefährliche Entwicklung. Die Frage ist halt, wie kann man dem begegnen, wie kann man Bewusstsein schaffen dagegen? Und ich sehe es im Augenblick nicht wirklich, die Chance da Bewusstsein.
Oh, ich war es nicht. Ich war es wirklich nicht.
Vielleicht ruf da noch mal an, mal gucken.
Vielleicht ruf da noch mal an. Die Nummer ist 0371 77 91. Vielleicht sagst du einfach deinen Satz zu Ende. Wie kann man Bewusstsein schaffen? Gut, fragen wir die Hörer. Wie kann man Bewusstsein schaffen?
0331 für Potsdam 7097110 033 für97110.
Wir brauchen ganz dringend Salzsteine dabei.
Wir brauchen ganz dringend Salzsteine dabei. Und dann ist auch Müller Magun vorbei. Andi, wie geht's dir?
Ja, das geht so. Mein Magen, der sagt so ein bisschen, hm.
Ja gut, aber es riecht noch nicht so euerlich, also es geht eigentlich noch ganz gut. Jetzt ist Chaosradio 58. Wir haben gefragt, wie man Bewusstsein schafft und wie ihr die überwacht, die euch überwachen. Genau. Die Nummer noch mal. Die Leitung ist eh gerade voll. 031 77 97 110 auf jeden Fall. Peter. Peter, mein Gott. Peter, guten Abend. Peter. Schade. Bei Peter stand auf meinem Bildschirm die Information, Peter wird abgehört. Das hätte ich jetzt gerne mal. Da ist Peter nochmal.
Warte, versuche es nochmal.
Peter.
Peter. Peter. Peter. Ja, Peter, du wirst abgehört.
Ja, genau. Von wem?
Von wem?
Noch von der Polizei.
Warum?
Peter.
Hallo?
Ja, Peter, du kannst jetzt auch sprechen gerne. Also du wirst ja eh abgehört.
Ja, das ist mir vollkommen egal. Hallo. Ich meine, was mich dabei bei der ganzen Sache stört, ist, dass...
Jetzt frag mal, warum wirst du abgehört?
Warum? Ja, also ich habe irgendwann mal Kontakt gekriegt zu jemandem, der mit Drogen zu tun hatte, ne? Also ich habe einen Job gesucht, habe mich mit denen in Verbindung gesetzt und wollte für den arbeiten, also ganz legal, mit Vertrag und alles. Und bin dann in so eine Sache geraten über Drogen, ja. Habe davon überhaupt nichts Ahnung gehabt, ich wusste gar nichts und...
Woher weißt du, dass du abgehört wirst?
Weil mir die Polizei das im Nachhinein gesagt hat. Sie hat mir auch Dinge erzählt aus meinen Gesprächen, aus mit meiner Lebensgefährtin, wo Aussicht entschließen konnte, seit wann das so alles passiert. Und dadurch hat man natürlich auch meine Tochter selber bei der Polizei wahnsinnige Probleme dadurch. Und durch diese Abhörerei und durch die ganzen Konsequenzen habe ich jetzt keinen Kontakt mehr zu meiner Tochter, weil die würde ihren Job verlieren. Und ich bin ja nur so einer aus dem Ausland und ich muss ja sagen, das war früher nicht so und das wäre früher auch nicht so gewesen. Das ist ja, ich meine, Freiheit, hier ist ja diese Freie oder Demokratie. Wo ist dieser Begriff in so einer Handlungsweise?
Es heißt ja auch nicht Freiheit, sondern freiheitlich.
Ja, freiheitlich, das ist okay. Aber ich meine, die haben damit erst mal geschafft, dass ich erst mal von meiner Tochter getrennt bin. Also ich weiß jetzt zurzeit nicht, vielleicht hört so Fritz, wo sie wohnt. Oder wo sie überhaupt lebt. Ich meine, gut, ich verstehe sie auf jeden Art, man wird ihr an Herz gelegt haben. Also pass auf, Mädel, jetzt lebst du so wie wir das sagen. Bist du deine Beamten-Tätigkeit los oder dein Beruf? Meine Lebensgefährtin ist die ehemalige Freundin von ihr. Und ich meine, braucht man nicht viel Fantasie, um zu wissen, was für Blödsinn auch mal so über Späße man über Telefon loslässt. Die dann so für Fakt genommen werden. Und wenn ich dann so dran denke, ich bin da dran schulden. Vor allen Dingen, was mich noch fiel, ich weiß nicht, ob das in der ehemaligen Bundesrepublik oder in der Bundesrepublik genauso war, dass man sagt, da ist ein Polizist ein Freund und Helfer. Wenn man mal überlegt, wo ist die Präventivarbeit, die vorbeugende Arbeit dieser Polizisten. Hätten sie mich nicht ansprechen können durch die Abhörerei? Sie haben viel Information, ihr habt mich vor irgendwelchen weiteren privaten Schäden oder irgendwie Sachen, in denen ich jetzt da rinrutsche, irgendwelche kriminellen Sachen. In dem drehen wir das wieder so, dass das alles auf die Reihe kommt. Da wartet man, dass man so richtig in die Fettnäppe springt und so richtig mit Beton an die Füße auf den Grund landet, damit sie einen auf den Kopf kloppen können. Ich meine, das ist doch irgendwo nicht Sinn der Sache. Und dann letztendlich gehen die Leute abends nach Hause und essen von meiner Kohle, die ich an den Steuer hier bezahle, ihr Armbrot. Und hätten mich aber an irgendwen da verheizt im Ausland. Haben mich wissentlich mit dem LKW ins Ausland fahren lassen und wussten, ich sollte da Drohungen laden. Ich meine, jetzt frage ich mich, was ist denn das nur für eine Polizei hier? Und jetzt soll ich irgendwo Kronzeuge sein und wenn ich der Kronzeuge bin, wo ist denn die Polizei, wenn die Jungs, die nach sieben Jahren knapp rauskommen, denn bei mir vor der Tür stehen, mit einem Lochmacher und dann die Tür aufmachen, bumm. Finden ist da irgendwo total daneben. Zu wenig steht denn so. Ich meine, die bringen, man ist ja nicht jetzt durch die Behörde, man hat ja das Leben nicht leichter gemacht, die kriegt, sondern man kriegt ja noch eine. Man steht ja wie dazwischen, zwischen zwei Rammböcke.
Und machst du denn auch Internet? Und verschlüsselst du da irgendwas oder ist das...
Nee, mache ich nicht. Weil ich, nee, ich hab mir, das ist mir jetzt auch vollkommen, ich sag mir, bei mir hat sich so eine Gleichgültigkeit eingeschlichen. Ich sag mir, wo sind die anderen, die sowas tun? Ich meine, die sind für mich irgendwo viel zu niedrig. Vom Charakter her sind die einfach daneben.
Aber es ist nicht schon ein bedrückendes Gefühl, wenn du weißt, dass irgendwie alles abgehört.
Ich bin ja nur wochenlang unterwegs, meine Lebensgefährtin zu. Meinung ist, da ist das Mädel, da bin ich. Und dann wissen wir es immer, dann hat man die fremden Ohren dazwischen.
Scheiß Gefühl, ne?
Na klar ist das Scheiße. Ich meine, man kriegt ja auch keine Info, das ist jetzt abgeschlossen, du bist jetzt abgeschaltet. Sondern ich gehe jetzt permanent davon aus, wenn ich den Hörer hochnehme, da sind die mit dem Löffel drin. Und dafür bezahle ich dann im Monat noch 600 Mark bei D2 oder weis ich wo. Muss ich noch eine Gebühr bezahlen? Ich meine, wenn die da ihre Löffel drin halten, soll sie die Hälfte von meiner Gebühr, meine Telefonrate mit übernehmen.
Der Abhör fände ich.
Und vor allen Dingen, was ich hier ja eigentlich nicht in Ordnung finde, ist, wer je nehme ich denn sowas? Ich meine, wenn man jetzt mal in so einen Organ drin, je Dezernat, weis ich wo, das ist doch vollkommen wurscht. Die bearbeiten irgendwelche kriminellen Sachen. Wer in welchem Dienst gerade...
Wir bestimmen Gerichte und das Problem ist, dass es aber so ziemlich jeder Richter darf im Moment. Und das soll auch, soweit ich weiß, im neuen Datenschutzgesetz ein bisschen eingeschränkt werden, dass nur noch bestimmte Gerichte das bestimmen dürfen, damit da nicht so ein Wildwuchs passiert, wie hier ja passiert.
Ja, ich sag ja, ich werde immer... Ich meine, ich hab 40 Jahre nachdem der einhebt und wurde da und musste hier diese ganze Medienflut über mich ergießen lassen, wo bloß 40 Prozent gestimmt hat und dann hieß es immer, dieser Polizeistaat... Also was ich hier erlebe, das ist irgendwo das Letzte. Also da kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mit identifizieren. Ich bin der Letzte, der sagen würde, ich würde zurückkommen. Aber der jetzt von der von der rechtlichen, vom Rechtsempfinden, also bin ich total enttäuscht, muss ich sagen. Auch die sind oft treten. Ich bin jetzt nur ja ständig, also ich hab vor Jahrhundert die Straße zugebracht. Also wenn mich die Polizei anspricht, sowas hat sowas, sowas gab es früher nicht. Die kommen auf dem Autobahnparkplatz mit ihren grün-weißen Autorufen fahren und blicken mich von den Lautsprecher voll. Also früher musste sie sagen, schön guten Tag, Wachmeister Pumphelhuber, mein Dienstgrad ist sowieso, Sie haben jetzt jedenfalls nach Bla-Bla gemacht. Aber die kommen an und blöken mich vom Autolautsprecher voll, um dann nachher trotzdem persönlich zu kommen und an das Auto und mich da voll zu niesen. Die reden mit mir, wie mein Vater nicht mehr mit mir geredet hat. Da waren es nicht an.
Das ist klasse. Peter, ich wirke dich hier mal ab, immerhin hast du die etwas bessere von zwei schlechten Alternativen erwischt.
Wie bitte?
Immerhin lebst du gerade in der etwas besseren, offensichtlich von den zwei schlechten Alternativen. Noch nicht mal.
Ich habe einfach, denke ich mal, auch einen persönlichen Schutzenjuden. Also ich kann da irgendwo nichts mehr umschubsen.
Ja gut, aber so weit sollte es ja eigentlich nicht kommen, dass man gleichgültig wird dem ganzen Mistgehen.
Ich meine, das hat mit Gleichgewürdigkeit eine Schwierigkeit, es gibt ja welche, die gehen auf das nächste Wohnhaus mit zwölf Etagen und springen runter, oder?
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ich meine, so, so. Davon muss man ja immer aussehen, wie leichtfertig gehen die mit irgendwelchen Zücheln um. Also ich sage mal so, im Osten früher, da haben die Züchelhater kein Geld verdient, die sind da bald verhungert am Hungerstrang. Aber wenn ich hier jetzt noch mal die Chance hätte, einen Beruf zu laden, ich würde Züchelhater werden.
Ein wunderbares Schlusswort, Peter. Wir haben noch jede Menge in der Leitung hängen.
Ja, 80 Prozent sind ja geschädigt.
Danke für deinen Anruf.
Wobei sich da dann doch die Frage stellt, kann ich nicht, ich rufe dich jetzt an, Frank. Einigermaßen wertig möglich wäre, über IP zu telefonieren, müsste ich doch genau diese IP-Telefonie auch verschlüsseln.
Es gibt auch Krypto-Telefone, das Problem ist nur, dass ich natürlich keinen Einblick in den Source Code habe. Sie sind auch wieder bei dem Stichpunkt Open Source. Natürlich bietet mir die Firma Siemens ein Krypto-Telefon an unter dem Produkt namens Topsec. Und sie versprechen mir, meine Kommunikation bleibt vertraulich. Und das Gleiche bietet mir die Krypto-Agenda Schweiz an.
Dazu hat Tron, den ihr wahrscheinlich auch noch vom Namen zumindest her kennt, im Rahmen seiner Diplomarbeit an diesem Krypto-Phone gearbeitet. Aber er konnte es aufgrund seines frühzeitigen Todes nicht mehr vollenden.
Arbeitest da jetzt jemand dran weiter oder liegt das jetzt?
Naja, das Problem, das Tron war, was die technischen Dokumentationen angeht, war vielleicht noch ein bisschen verbesserungsbedürftig. Deswegen ist es da, glaube ich, Strickenwerfer zu ziehen und seine Gedankengänge nachzuvollziehen. Also ich habe mir die persönlich jetzt so nicht in die Tiefe angeguckt. Eine Firma, die da irgendwie als Geld reinsteckt, und auch irgendwie zehn Leute bezahlt, die das irgendwie in zwei Monaten machen, denke ich ist aber kein Problem.
Naja, es gibt da gerade ein Unternehmen, das versucht hat, ein Krypto-Telefon zu basteln und was merkwürdigerweise aufgrund irgendwelcher Aufsichtsgradentscheidungen dieses Produkt nun nicht vermarktet. Und da stellt sich auch die Frage, wer entscheidet darüber und welche Einflusskreise nehmen da Einfluss und verhindern, dass die Markteinführung ist. Es gibt seit vielen, vielen Jahren Pläne für Krypto-Telefone. Es gibt auch Krypto-Telefonie seit, ich weiß nicht, 50, 60 Jahren. Aber eben nur für Industriekunden, Militärkunden.
Na aber doch, die, die, irgendjemand hat das erzählt in Holland auf einer Party oder war es Hamburg? Also möglicherweise gibt es da irgendwie eine andere.
Wir reden uns um Kopf und Kran. Bleiben wir doch einfach mal in der Rubrik interessante Geschichten. Hallo Verena.
Ja, hallo.
Was ist deine interessante Geschichte?
Meine interessante Geschichte ist, also ich habe im Urlaub in Niederlande, in Amsterdam, einen Menschen kennengelernt, der jahrelang auf diesem Sektor gearbeitet hat, also Observation, Equipment-Entwicklung, also er hat Elektronik studiert, also gelernt und sowas alles und hat ziemlich viel selbst gebastelt, hat auch viele Abnehmer gehabt, auch vom Staat und so weiter, nicht nur von Niederländischen und hat halt kleine Spielzeuge entwickelt, Spionagesachen und Wanzen und so weiter und auch Dinge, also Werkzeug, um so etwas aufzuspüren und da Groundwissen auf diesem Sektor und ich möchte ihn natürlich nicht kompromotieren und ich kenne ihn ja eigentlich auch nicht, deswegen rufe ich an. Ich habe ihn nur kennengelernt und gute Gespräche geführt darüber, sehr interessante Gespräche und wenn ich das jetzt natürlich erwähne und wenn alles abgehört wird, ist es natürlich scheiße.
Es wird ja eh gerade abgehört und zwar über diverse UKW-Fräden.
Ich hoffe, er hört mich nicht aus so einem Vertrauensbruch. Jedenfalls, er meinte, dass Niederlande sehr viel schlimmer ist als Deutschland zum Beispiel, weil du vorhin ja meintest irgendwie, Deutschland ist relativ das mit dem höchsten Markt dieses Gleichens irgendwie.
Nicht der Markt, sondern die Anzahl, die er anschließt.
Also kurzentual soll Niederlande viel stärker sein. Also wirklich ganz gut überwacht.
Also in welchen Zahlen man da trauen darf? Die Frage ist ja auch, inwiefern die Zahlen stimmen, die man über die...
Genau. Und Statistik ist sowieso alles Müll, denke ich mal. Aber er ist halt damit wirklich auf Tuflöchung gekommen. Und deswegen, wenn ich seine Worte zitiere, dann ist das halt so. Und man weiß ja auch nicht, was in Übersee ist oder so. Weil es ist wahrscheinlich noch viel schlimmer.
In Amerika sind die Zahlen geringer, wenn ich es mal einwerfen darf. Also in Amerika wird weniger abgehört als in Deutschland.
Ja, aber wer weiß das schon?
Die Sicherheit, dass das so ist, gewinnt man nicht. Die Frage ist halt nur, inwieweit traut man den Berichten, die veröffentlicht werden in unserer Demokratie?
Und das sollte man wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht. Was da alles im Untergrund ist, jeder hat ja so seine Theorien irgendwie oder so ein Gefühl davon oder macht sich seine Gedanken. Was da eigentlich viele sagen, die fürchten sich mehr, also Amerikaner auch irgendwie, die fürchten sich mehr vor der CIA als vor der Mafia oder sonst irgendwas. Das ist echt wirklich schlimm. Na ja, ist egal, wir kommen vom Thema ab. Und jedenfalls irgendwann in seine Laufbahn, er hat ziemlich viele Bereiche auch auf diesem elektronischen Sektor abgestrichen. Er hat jetzt aufgehört damit, weil es ihm zu viel wird, weil er zu viel Backgroundwissen hat und mit Sachen kompromotiert wird, die nicht gut für ihn sind irgendwie. Hat er auch gemeint, dass er irgendwann mal ein Telefon entwickelt hat oder irgendwas, womit der User, der Benutzer irgendwie immer wieder eine andere Nummer wählen konnte, eine andere Nummer für sich haben konnte, sodass er Gebühren spart und sowas alles. Leider hat er den Fehler gemacht, also ich hab's nicht genau begriffen, wie das funktionierte, leider hat er den Fehler gemacht, Nummern aus Deutschland zu nehmen. Und dadurch hat er einmal Probleme mit dem Staat bekommen, mit Deutschland, als wir mal dort im Urlaub waren. Wir haben ihn halt festgenommen und haben irgendwie das Angebot bereitet. Du kannst weitermachen mit dieser kleinen Spielerei, mit dieser Erfindung, die viel Geld eingebracht hat, aber du musst uns die Nummern sagen. Also du musst immer wieder uns auf den besten Spann bringen und so weiter. Und damit sie halt auch abhören können und dies und das. Und irgendwie ist das schon ziemlich interessant gewesen, was du so erzählst. Also was da alles für kleine Kooperationen möglich sind. Oder dass sie auch den Wunsch haben, irgendwie Bescheid zu wissen und alles zu kontrollieren. Wissen ist Macht. Und es ist ganz klar, dass dieser Wunsch da ist von einem Polizeistaat, von einem guten Staat, wirklich über alles Bescheid zu wissen.
Ja und da aber selbst nicht über die Fähigkeiten und Fertigkeiten zu verfügen, sich dieses Wissen zu verschaffen. Das finde ich irgendwie immer so witzig. Dass die Staatsorgane dann selbst gar nicht über die Fähigkeiten und Fertigkeiten verfügen, sich das Wissen anzueignen und darum dann mal lieber jemanden einlochen und ihm sagen, jetzt erzähl.
Das ist ja auch eine Frage der technischen Entwicklung. Das Problem, was ich sehe, ist, dass wir uns immer noch darauf verlassen, dass es juristische Safe Guards gibt, die eben diese Maßnahmen verhindern. Und sicherlich ist der große Bruder...
Das muss unbedingt sein, auf alle Fälle für Menschenrechte und so weiter und so fort.
Aber was eigentlich wirklich abläuft?
Was eigentlich wirklich abläuft, also nicht unbedingt von Polizei oder von diesen Organisationen, aber andere Organisationen, wie flott sie da drauf sind und wie viele Möglichkeiten sie haben technologisch.
Da ist eben die Frage, ob man nicht diese juristischen Rückhalte, die ja doch auch immer wieder durchregend sind und ausgehöhlt werden... Das muss bestehen bleiben. Sicherlich müssen die bestehen bleiben. Die Frage ist nur, wie weit kann man die durch technische Maßnahmen ergänzen? Und warum gibt es noch keinen Anbieter, der eben für die Bürger Krypto-Telefone anbietet zu einem Preis von 40, 50 Mark? Was ist das Problem dabei? Ist das technisch sicherlich möglich?
Aber es würden sich ja so viele aneignen, auch wichtige Personen, die man observieren muss, in deren Meinung. Und deswegen können sie das nicht auf den Markt werfen.
Naja, das Problem ist doch aber nur, dann müsste ich, wenn man so denkt, die Strafe für die Nutzung von Kryptographie ohne Hinterlegung von Feilschlüsseln, wenn wir davon sprechen möchten, höher sein als die Strafandrohung für die Straftaten, die über diese Leitung besprochen werden. Denn ich bin mir sicher, dass ein Verbrecher, der ein Verbrechen plant oder jemand, der zukünftig ein Verbrecher wird, in dem er Verbrechen durchführt, diese nicht über eine ungesicherte Leitung plant. Denn die Frage ist eben, wenn er sie plant und sie entdeckt werden, damit kommt da eine Strafe für die Vorbereitungshandlungen? Und warum sollte er da nicht Kryptographie nutzen? Denn dann müsste die Strafe für die Nutzung von Kryptographie höher sein als für sämtliche Straftaten, die er plant.
Ja, weil das müsste berücksichtigt werden, weil das ist ja erstmal die Voraussetzung, um so etwas zu planen. Natürlich kann man das auch privat machen, irgendwie in einem Ort, wo definitiv keine Wanzen sind oder sowas. Aber es ist, ja, das ist echt ein schwieriger Fall irgendwie. Den kann man nicht so ohne Weiteres klären, dann wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie. Aber wenn man das...
Also Frankreich, glaube ich, hat ja da auf diesen Abschreckungsfaktor gesetzt. Da hat man gesagt, wir verbieten irgendwie Verschlusselung. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das noch aktuell ist, ob das noch aufrecht erhalten ist. Das heißt also, da gibt es dann halt relativ milde Strafen irgendwie, allein für den Einsatz von Verschlusselung. Das soll als Abschreckung so dienen. Das heißt, es soll gar keiner auf die Idee kommen, Leute, wenn sie verschlüsseln, gehen halt irgendwie so lange in den Knast, bis sie es sein lassen, so einfach gesagt. Für den Staat, ja.
Für den Staat ist es gut.
Und wie soll man als kleiner Bürger dagegen angehen, irgendwie?
Na ja, interessant ist ja, dass die Industrie das irgendwie nicht so witzig findet. Und mittlerweile ist ja auch so eine kleine Trendwende. Es gibt in Deutschland eine kleine Trendwende, dass die Regierung mittlerweile auch gesehen hat, dass die Industrie das nicht so toll findet.
Und eigentlich ist ja auch die Theorie, dass die Industrie oder die Wirtschaft eigentlich die wirkliche Macht hat irgendwo. Und dass da wirklich eine gute Kooperation möglich sein müsste irgendwo.
Zwischen Industrie und Staat.
Ja. Also ich denke mal, dass sie sehr großen Wert darauf legen, einfach finanziell. Dieser Aspekt ist ja wirklich nicht zu verachten. Was sie dadurch für Geld machen könnten, mit diesen Geräten irgendwie. Weil man sich ja wünscht, gerade nach diesen Skandalen oder nach der Bewusstwerdung dieser Problematik, was ihr ja irgendwie gerade macht unter anderem, zur Frage, wie kann man das bewusst machen? Ja, jetzt hab ich den Faden verloren.
Das Problem ist doch aber dabei, dass viele, die sogenannten braven Bürger, sagen, na, ich hab ja nichts zu verbergen. Hört mich doch ruhig ab, ich hab ja nichts zu verbergen.
Naja, aber es geht ja viele an den Stolz oder an die Eitelkeit irgendwie, dass die ganzen Dinge, die man so für wichtig hält, irgendwie tausend Leute hören und sich darüber amüsieren oder sowas, keine Ahnung.
Allein die Vorstellung ist schrecklich, ne?
Genau, genau. Und das sollte man echt nicht machen. Aber eigentlich läuft das ja wirklich. Es ist einem nicht bewusst oder sowas. Also so weit mir dieser Bekannte aus Amsterdam sagte, gibt es diese Spielereien und die werden angewendet. Und es ist vielsehr größer, als man sich das vorstellt. Und viel länger geht das schon, als man sich das vorstellt. Also ist diese Thematik, soll man verbieten, soll man verschlüsseln können, glaube ich, das wäre eigentlich sowieso auch nicht notwendig, weil es läuft ja sowieso anders. Ob wir das wissen und einsetzen dürfen oder nicht, das ist die Frage.
Es gibt aber glücklicherweise auch Bestrebungen. Ich habe hier zum Beispiel eine Meldung aus Telepolis vom 16. Februar. Das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium hat offensichtlich erkannt, was hier passiert, und fördert einen Anonymisierungsdienst. Es ist schon Bewusstsein da. Das Problem ist, dass Regierungen in einer Demokratie Mehrheitsmeinungen wahrnehmen. Die zu vertreten, ist ein schwieriger Punkt. Sofern sie das erkennen, führen sie es auch durch. Das einzige Problem, das ich augenblicklich sehe, ist, Bewusstsein zu schaffen.
Die Frage liegt nur da, um die Leute zu beruhigen. Und läuft es nicht eigentlich anders ab?
Da komme ich irgendwann an einen Punkt, wo ich das Thema dieser Sendung überschreite, in dem ich an einem Punkt angelange, wo ich alles in Frage stelle.
Das sollte man eigentlich, wenn man Philosophieren möchte.
Macht einmal, aber das Leben bestimmt nicht einfacher.
Nicht direkt, nein.
Das Problem kommt nicht weiter, sondern wird eher resigniert. Man muss sich schon damit befassen. Man müsste den Schwerpunkt auf die juristischen Fragen der Anwendung dieses Wissens konzentrieren.
Was nutzen die juristischen Fragen der Anwendung? Sie werden es tun.
Die Möglichkeiten der Polizei oder der Geheimdienste oder sonst irgendwas, damit dann was anzufangen. Oder das dann wirklich festzumachen.
Du kannst ja in Gesetze reinschreiben. Die Musik ist zu leise, dann leuchtet hier eine rote Lampe, dann steht da ein Senderausfall, das ist lustig. Nein, wir hatten keinen Senderausfall, falls das irgendwo vermerkt werden sollte. Die Musik war einfach nur ein bisschen zu leise. Wo stand der Senderausfall?
Wenn, dann Fritz.
032.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Nachts kaum noch Schnee bei minus 5 bis minus 10 Grad. Morgen dann Anfangs trügt später Aufheiterung bei minus 1 bis plus 2 Grad. Also eigentlich so wie vor einer Stunde.
Die israelische Arbeitspartei hat sich am Abend für eine Regierungsbeteiligung entschieden. An der Abstimmung über eine Koalition mit dem Liquidblock des gewählten Ministerpräsidenten Sharon nahmen weniger als die Hälfte der Delegierten teil. Für das Parteienbündnis hatte vor allem Friedensnobelpreisträger Perez geworben, der als künftiger Außenminister im Gespräch ist. In Bonn hat sich der zentrale Krisenstab des Bundesverbraucherministeriums auf ein 6-Punkte-Programm gegen die Maul und Küche bekannt. Die Europäische Union öffnet ihre Märkte für Produkte aus der dritten Welt. Die EU-Außenminister billigten in Brüssel gegen den Willen Frankreichs an der entsprechenden Vorlage der EU-Kommission. Die Zollbeschränkungen sollen langsam liberalisiert und bis zum Jahr 2009 völlig abgeschafft werden. Im Fall der verschwundenen Ulrikus Eberswald ist der Fahrer eines weißen Pkw tatverdächtig. Nach dem etwa 20- bis 30-Jahre alten 1, 75 m großen Mann werde bundesweit gefahrendet, sagte heute ein Polizeisprecher. Beim Abgang einer Lawine an der Zugspitze ist heute eine Frau ums Leben gekommen. Sie erlag in einem Krankenhaus, ihren Verletzungen. Zwei weitere Personen konnten sich aus eigener Kraft aus der Lawine befreien. Der Verkehr im Landkreis Spree-Neisef, ja so heißt es, später möchtest du es sagen? Was? Also Fuß vom Gas.
Vielen Dank, Herr Kocknig.
Echt, wirklich?
Nein, ich fasse es nicht.
Okay, ihr seid halt nicht ganz allein mit ihr.
Nicht?
Naja, es könnte sein, dass am 25. März, ein Sonntag übrigens, und auch noch der an dem die Sommerzeit beginnt, also es könnte sein, dass an diesem Tag noch ein paar andere Leute in der Columbia-Halle sind.
Aber?
Immerhin.
Ja.
Also, Kylie Minogue kommt für eine Nacht nach Berlin.
25. 20 Uhr. Columbia Halle.
Von Fritz.
Man muss sich dieses Ding anziehen, bevor man sprechen kann. Ich kann dich hören, kannst du mich hören? Könnt ihr uns hören? 0037 ist Fritz, das Chaosradio Nummer 58. Wie war das jetzt? Jetzt hab ich die Seite weggemacht. Wie hieß unser Thema? Ich fand das so schön.
Das klingt so gut.
Was?
Unser Allgemeines Thema.
Unser Allgemeines Thema, ja kann man da nochmal sagen.
Denn alle Gesetze und virtuelle Straftaten war der Titel. Und die Fragestellung war gerade, ob die Leute Paranoia schieben oder wir Paranoia schieben und...
Ob das vielleicht alles gar nicht so schlimm ist.
Richtig und ich guck jetzt mal, wer hier am längsten wartet, wer am längsten in der Leitung hängt, ist der Steve. Ich würde gerne wissen, ob du dir eine bessere Position mit deinem Handy suchen könntest, damit wir dich auch verstehen.
Leider, ich finde es wahnsinnig wohl, wa? Haupt die Überwachung in einem Intranet, sprich in einem NT-Netzwerk.
Also du meinst jetzt ein Intranet mit einem Firmeninternen Netzwerk.
Genau, ein Firmeninternes Netzwerk. Ist es möglich, dass der Chef komplett alles sieht, was ich mache, oder nicht?
Technisch ja, juristisch nein, aber da gibt es auch so ein paar Punkte.
Also in Deutschland zumindest wird es schwierig so etwas durchzudrücken.
Also eigentlich, er könnte mir nichts sagen.
Also er kann natürlich schon, nur er darf es halt nicht.
Also er darf es halt nicht verwenden und so weiter.
Er darf es eigentlich auch nicht durchführen. Das Problem ist auch, inwiefern dir beispielsweise E-Mail am Arbeitsplatz zur Verfügung gestellt wird, inwiefern dir da ein privater Nutzen zugesichert wird, also ob du private Mails über deinen Firma-Account schreiben darfst.
Wobei wir hier keine Rechtsberatung machen dürfen. Also so ist, glaube ich, so meiniges Lesen zu haben. Ganz vorsichtig.
Naja, das wäre ja nicht schlecht, oder?
Steve, das war's? Nächstes Sitzfleisch hat Gerhard.
Hallo. Ja, und zwar gab es vor kurzem auf der Seite vom CCC ein Artikel, warum RC 5D erst böse ist, und dieser Link ist irgendwie verschwunden.
Unser Web-Server, falsche Frage, bitte.
Und zwar war da ein Hinweis auf die SETI-Projekt. Und das war sehr interessant, weil da beteiligen sich 2, 5 Millionen Rechner dran und kein Mensch weiß, was da für eine Daten berechnet werden und letztendlich an irgendwelche Server in den Staaten übertragen werden. Und das hat mich doch sehr nachdenklich gestimmt. Und ich habe daraufhin meine ganzen SETI-Aktivitäten hier komplett eingestellt.
Weil obendrauf ja dann auch noch irgendwie davon auszugehen, dass man da mit tatsächlich außerirdisches intelligentes Leben findet, eigentlich der größte Unsinn ist, den man sich noch vorstellen kann. Und ausschließlich dazu dient, Mars-Raum-Flugprogramme irgendwie zu promoten.
Naja, also es ist schön zu sehen, dass unsere Aktionen tatsächlich einen Echo haben zu dem Problem mit dem verschwundenen Link. Wir gestalten gerade wieder mal unseren Webserver um und das geschiebt ganz offensichtlich nicht ohne kleinere Reibereien, aber ich hoffe, dass es wieder auftritt. Kollateralschäden. Das Problem dabei ist natürlich die grundsätzliche Frage nach dem Vertrauen in Software. Wie weit möchte ich denn Quellen ausgeliefert werden, das Open-Source-Software? Allerdings deutlich weniger, nachdem eben kompetente Menschen den Einblick in die Software nehmen können, Sicherheitslücken aufdecken können. Und das kann ich halt bei Binär-Programmen nicht. Auch die Frage stellt sich, warum installieren sich so viele Leute Napster? Im Fall von Napster ist es ja noch so, dass ich zumindest das Protokoll analysieren kann, was da gesprochen wird, das ist mittlerweile reverse-ingeniert. Auch noch ein ganz interessantes Stichpunkt. Und ich kann feststellen, was dieser Client tatsächlich mit den Server-Innenstaaten spricht und kann davon ausgehen, dass keine personenbezogenen Daten übermittelt werden, jedenfalls nicht weitergehend denen, die ich ohnehin eingetragen habe. Weil seht ihr hingegen, weiß ich grundsätzlich gar nicht, was da passiert. Ich bekomme irgendwelche unklaren Binärdaten und ich übertrage irgendwelche Binärdaten.
Also ich war da auch sehr dankbar für diesen Hinweis. Ich hab mich nur geärgert, dass ich nicht selbst...
Vielleicht ist es auch gar nicht so.
Aber es ist durchaus denkbar. Es ist denkbar, dass man nicht unbedingt ein Anhänger von Verschwörungstheorien ist, dass das ein getarntes Unternehmen ist, von irgendwelchen Regierungen, Behörden...
Das ist halt auch wieder ein Problem des Vertrauens, des gegenseitigen Vertrauens, des Vertrauens in Software, die ich nicht kenne, aus fremder Quelle. Und es ist halt schon so, dass ich... Mittlerweile zeigt sich das ja auch an diversen Fake-Websites, dass ich Vertrauen beim Benutzer relativ leicht gewinnen kann, indem ich eine seriös aussehende Website generiere. Und ähm... Seeland. Wie weit möchte ich einer Website vertrauen, die seriös aussieht? Wer garantiert mir denn, was dahinter steht? Wer garantiert mir, dass tatsächlich das passiert, was dort steht? Insofern ist eine gewisse Rechtssicherheit und Vertrauensschaffung im Netz eingestellt.
Also ich sage mal, Transparenz schafft Vertrauen. Also das meint irgendwie, dass wer offenlegt, was er macht, und wenn alle reingucken können, dann ist einfach auch klar, dem kann ich vertrauen. Als Grundprinzip.
Ja, nee, ich wollte das nochmal so als zusätzlichen Aspekt einwerfen. Das gilt als größtes, ich glaube größtes, gemeinschaftliches Computerprojekt, was läuft so weltweit und von daher.
Ja, und das ist ja auch irgendwie einer der nächsten Trends, irgendwie dieses Distributed Computing, wo du einfach dann auch eventuell noch ein paar Fänige dafür bekommst, dass du auf deinem Rechner Sachen rechnen lässt, von denen du eben auch nicht weißt, was es ist.
.zu vertrauen. Und Luciane Schulz, GH Dutti, die immer sehr lesenswerte Dokumente verfasst, das unter dem Titel Schraube um Informationsfreiheit in Europa dreht sich enger. Deutschland votiert für noch mehr Geheimhaltung. In den USA gibt es den sogenannten Freedom of Information Act, über den Journalisten zu interessanten Themen Dokumente der Regierung verlangen können und diese ihnen auch ausgehechentigt werden muss auf Kosten des Staates. Die Frage ist, wie weit der Zugang zu Informationen ein Grundbedürfnis und ein Grundrecht des Bürgers ist. Augenblicklich ist es halt kein Grundrecht des Bürgers, sondern nur ein Grundbedürfnis, was auch immer stärker anwächst. Und Herrschende versuchen natürlich auch diese Transparenz zu verhindern, nachdem es ihnen eine zusätzliche Kontrolle von Seiten des Bürgers aufbürdet.
Ja klar, für die Behörden ist es mehr abwurzend.
Es wäre schön, wenn wir auch in Deutschland so ein Freedom of Information Act hätten, so ein Gesetz für Informationsfreiheit. Das fehlt halt noch, naja.
Wer kann es wo einbringen? Können wir es irgendwo einbringen?
Petition.
Na ja, es ist halt momentan ein EU-Sonderausschuss, der nicht offen ist. Kann man noch einen Anrufer?
Ja, einen haben wir noch. Tony!
Ja, also ruf eigentlich an, wegen der IP-Geschichte nochmal auf dem Telefon. Aber, ja, das kann ich dir ja nicht vorstellen. Zum Beispiel hier online, die haben doch auch massige User, dass sie da alle mitloggen können.
Na ja, also bei dieser Runde, als es um die Abhörmaßnahmen auf Europaebene ging, diese Cybercrime-Convention, hat man schon gesagt, zum Beispiel steht in dieser Berichtlinie drin, es soll in Echtzeit, also IP und Echtzeit widerspricht sich einfach komplett. Also Telefon ist irgendwie klar, aber wenn ein Paket über die Leitung geht, dann ist das irgendwie nicht mehr in Echtzeit, das ist alles ein bisschen schwierig. Und wenn die Leute irgendwie alle jetzt DSL haben oder noch mehr, dann brauchen die irgendwann megafette Leitungen und das kostet so richtig viel Technik alles. Und die müssen ja auch an jedem Einwahlpunkt, dadurch dass sie keinen zentralen Router haben, wo alles durchläuft, das geht auch technisch gar nicht, dadurch müssen die überall an den ganzen Punkten irgendwie ihre Abhörsoftware oder Abhörgeräte haben. Und das ist natürlich ein ganz fürchterlicher Aufwand für die.
Und selbst dann wird es Lösungen geben, wie zum Beispiel, ich hab mir überlegt, so eine Art Socks-Protokoll zwischen zwei Hosts, dann bloß mit einer verschlüsselten Socks-Protokoll.
Na das heißt dann IP-Sektion.
Das ist doch schon wieder zu nicht demacht.
Na also, wir sprechen hier nur von Telefonieverkehr. Telefonie in Daten zu packen, ist ohnehin ein ganz anderer Vorgang. Telefonie kann ich noch in Echtzeit abhören, Paket-Transport ist schon schwieriger und wenn ich eben Paketvermittelnde Netze habe, die mir auch verschlüsselte Pakete verschicken, weil es ja nur ein weiterer Datentyp ist, kann ich da natürlich Sprache mit reinpacken und die kann in eine lange Nase drehen. Das Problem ist halt nur die Niederschwelligkeit des Zugangs. Natürlich kann ich sagen, wir Hacker basteln uns ein Krypto-Telefon, auch wenn das momentan noch nicht so richtig toll klappt. Aber die Frage ist halt auch nach dem sogenannten gemeinen Bürger, dem diese Techniken eben nicht zur Verfügung stehen. Und hier entwickelt sich sicherlich eine digitale Zwei-Klassen-Gesellschaft. Und das ist definitiv nicht wünschenswert.
Und dazu kommt ja auch, dass sie es nicht nur machen. Also gib mir deine Daten und du kriegst es billiger. So diese Version Payback, genau.
Payback, unsere Freunde von Payback, ja.
Ja und, ach man, mir fällt hier eine Teilenbrücke in der Warteschacht auf.
Also ich hab auf meinem Display stehen, glaubt nicht an totale Kontrolle.
Also erstmal, mir wäre eher, wenn man mir die Telefonleitung abhören würde, wenn ich telefoniere.
Echt?
Echt? Schreibst du auch Briefe manchmal?
Wie, Briefe?
Naja, Briefe. Nicht. Wenn du es tun würdest, würdest du es auf Postkarten schreiben oder würdest du es in Umschlag tun?
Gut, das ist halt andere. Wenn ich jetzt vertrauliche Sachen zum Beispiel, dann würde ich die schon in Umschlag tun, aber sonst rufen.
Da ist die Frage, brenne Leute was an. Möchtest du, wenn du mit deiner Freundin telefonierst, dass jemand mithört?
Ja, gar nicht unbedingt, nicht unbedingt, nicht zwingend, aber... Ich werde mich nicht sehr stören, eigentlich nicht. Ich meine, ich werde mir sicher sein, dass da werden sich ja nicht irgendwelche Leute hinsetzen, die da von Beruf und so keine Ahnung haben. Die hören sich den ganzen Tag an und werden dann nicht so, ach, der und der hat ja mit dem und...
Nee, ist schon klar.
Na Moment, warum sollten sie es nicht machen? Warum sollten sie es nicht machen? Warum sollten sie genau das nicht machen? Sie können es, also werden sie es doch tun. Ich sag an so einer Stelle immer, warum leckt der und sich die Eier?
Die Frage ist doch, wenn... Also es gibt ja irgendwie eine große Masse, irgendwie 79 Millionen Menschen oder sowas, die kommunizieren alle ganz normal, unverschlüsselt, doch sofort die Alarmglocken, weil da Polizei überall an, ah, da ist jemand verschlüsselt, da passiert bestimmt jetzt was ganz Geheimnis und Hochkriminell und da müssen wir jetzt gleich erstmal irgendwie hinfahren und irgendwie an der Wand horchen, weil das Telefon können wir ja nicht abhören. Das ist so das Problem. Das heißt, im Moment ist es so, dass die Leute, die Verschlüsselung benutzen, fallen auf. Das Ziel muss aber sein, dass es ganz normal ist, Verschlüsselung zu benutzen, dass es halt nicht mehr auffällt, dass es völlig normal ist.
Na gut, dann kann aber. Ich mache das halt eher über das Internet, so textbasierend.
Das ist noch viel leichter, alles mitzulesen, vor allem auch die E-Mails auf Stichwörter irgendwie durchzugucken und dann landen die nämlich ganz gezielt bei den entsprechenden Sachbearbeitern. Wenn sie verschlüsselt sind, dann nicht, ne, das ist richtig.
Gibt ja. Ist ja eigentlich überhaupt kein Problem.
Benutzt du das denn?
Warum nicht? Also ich meine, weil du glaubst, dass es nicht brauchst oder weil es zu kompliziert ist?
Normalerweise so, über die erzählen ist ja kein Problem, aber jetzt, wenn es umgekehrt ist, dann muss es schon, dann verschlüsselt es schon. Nee, wer soll mich denn kontrollieren, aus welchem Grund? Ich muss dir erstmal einen Grund liefern. Mit der Verschlüsselung kann ein Grund sein. Aber wie viele Hots in Deutschland sind, die sich mal erlauben, Verschlüssel zu chatten oder so? Und dann noch die ganzen Server, also HTTP, da sind ja auch SSF-Verschlüsselungen.
Na gut, dann kann ich aber Zielanalysen machen. Ich sehe immer noch, welche Website er sich angeguckt hat. Ich sehe den Inhalt natürlich nicht, aber ich sehe, welche Website er sich anguckt.
Ich sehe, dass die Anzahl der mit PGP verschlüsselten Mails, die irgendwie in Deutschland kursieren, dass die noch, also das ist eine abzählbare Menge, denke ich. Also im Vergleich zu allen E-Mails, die durchgehen. Und wenn da welche gehäuft auftauchen, dann könnten die natürlich als Interessenschwerpunkte für weitere Forschungen dann auffallen. Okay, das ist jetzt ein bisschen paranoia, aber...
Das sieht gluhweiß aus, also kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Das hört sich an wie hier, wie der Film da hieß da. Nee, wo der im ganzen Körper die Wanzen hatte und so.
Ganzen Körper Wanzen, Matrix?
Um zwei für zwei immer.
Um zwei für immer Matrix. Toni, vielen Dank an dieser Stelleinflug von deinem Anruf.
Weil ich bin ja nun echt paranoid, ja. Ich hab wirklich die Bescheidung, dass ich paranoid bin, aber ich würde mich interessieren, ist es möglich, Handys, sagen wir mal, über Satelliten genau zu orten und so weiter, oder kann man das jetzt nur...
Warum über Satelliten passiert terrestrisch?
Also, weil allein das Netz muss ja schon wissen, wo du bist, weil die können ja nicht irgendwie wie ein Radiosender irgendwie alle Gespräche quer über Deutschland verteilen, sondern nur genau zu deinem nächsten Mast, Sendemast. Das heißt, da bist du schon einmal im Grenzen. Dann gibt es noch einen Nachbarmast, der dich auch im Visier hat, weil im Zweifelsfall, wenn der eine irgendwie schwächer wird, dann kann der andere übernehmen. Und dann weißt du schon, du bist zwischen den beiden und kannst da ziemlich genau, ich weiß nicht, was der aktuelle Standung ist. Das geht ohne Satellit.
Alles klar, aber da ich ja vom Beruf Diplomengeologe bin und mich früher mit Satellitentechnik auch beschäftigt habe, Infrarot-Fotos ausgewertet habe, Equidensiten-Falschfarben-Fotos und so weiter, und da ist mir bekannt, dass man sehr genau eben schon Dinge erkennen kann über Satellit. Da würde mich interessieren inwieweit die IRS, also die internationale Space Station, in weit die herangezogen wird, um hier Leute zu überwachen, vielleicht für Versuchszwecke, um dann eben an Informationen ranzukommen. Habt ihr da irgendwelche Informationen? Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das auf jeden Fall im militärischen Bereich, da wird ja das meiste gemacht, da wird das meiste Geld investiert. 80 ist ja nun schon eine Ewigkeit hier. Ich mache mir jetzt keinen Kopf darum. Aber ich habe ja auch oft genug im Wahrheitsvolumen angerufen und meine Storys erzählt. Genauso, wenn ihr am Ende die Rufnummer 110 habt, dann könnte ich mir denken, ich rufe bei der Polizei an.
Das geht aber jetzt zu weit.
Nein, das war ein Spat hier.
Ich wollte nur sagen, soweit geht es ja bei mir nicht.
Nur weil du paranoid bist, heißt es nicht, dass sie nicht wirklich hinter dir her sind?
Genau so heißt es.
Das wollte ich eigentlich damit so ausdrücken. Ich habe mal die Erschirungsgeschichte meiner angeblichen Krankheit geschildert einer Mitarbeiterin der deutschen Angestelltenkrankasse. In dem Augenblick, wenn ich dazu in der Lage war, da voll auszupacken, dann ist meine Leitung gekappt worden.
Ich erinnere mich, wir hatten schon mal einen Blumen, da hast du angerufen, da ging es auch um das Thema und hast die Geschichte auch weitestgehend erzählt, was ich sehr interessant fand. Vielleicht machen wir der einst noch mal so eine Sendung, dann erzählst du sie noch mal in aller Breite.
Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen spät zugeschaltet, aber ich wollte doch noch mal das kurz anführen, sowas gibt es wirklich. Und die Leute werden dann eben als paranoid erklärt, dadurch sind sie ungefährlich und jeder Ansicht, diese Schildern, der wird als verrückt abgetan.
Jörg, wir müssen leider Schluss machen. Alles klar, danke für deinen Anruf, tschüss. So, das war's, ne? Musik, ja, nee, wir sind jetzt...
Wir haben noch eine Bitte an Siemens, auch Bitte. Wir sind nämlich, es gibt da eine Seite enthalten, Criminal Skills, und berlin.ccc, also die lokale Domain, sozusagen von Berlin enthält, online Merchandising, E-Commerce oder sowas, und die hamburg.ccc ist Online Entertainment, also bitte guckt euch diese Kategorien doch mal an, weil wir kriegen viele Mails, dass die Leute da zum Beispiel die Unis am Brücken sperrt irgendwie unsere Seiten, das finden wir halt nicht so lustig.
Heftig, das war es, Chaosradio 58. Andy ist schon irgendwie, ja, der hat sich draußen abgewartet, weil dem ging es nicht so gut.
Genau, wir hatten mal alle wieder gesund.
Vielen Dank Frank, vielen Dank Andreas.
Gute Nacht Chaosradio.
Gute Nacht, Chaosradio wieder am letzten Montag im März, dann mit Nummer 59 und einem noch anzukündigen Thema. Ach so, hier gibt es jetzt gleich den Nightfly, meines Erachtens gibt es ihn mit MC Lücke, den habe ich aber noch nicht.